the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
where fireworks across the boards at the
Cairns Cup in St Louis the coveted cup
is a prize worth fighting for with yet
another day filled with decisive battles
Alexandra castenia got down to business
to defeat Co number one harika dronabali
climbing to Seoul lead over the field
Elizabeth paid Soldier down through a
tough first-round loss and like a
phoenix returned with the strength of a
raging fire defeating her opponent to
earn her first win of the event a queen
stands alone atop the standings will she
conquer her foes or will a challenger
arise day three of explosive chess
coming up next
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone welcome back to round
three of the Karen's cup here in San
Luis I'm very excited to be in the San
Luis chess club where you can play a
game or just watch the broadcast live
without further Ado let's go to the
studio and get the action started
welcome to San Luis the home of Chess in
America and the third edition of the
Karens cup one of the richest women's
tournaments in chess we come to you live
from the San Luis chess club
thank you
good morning and welcome everyone thank
you for joining us I'm International
Master naziabai kids and I'm here with
Grandmaster Yasser serum Nazi we are
having a lot of fun aren't we what what
an event to be broadcasting the decisive
games incredible hello everyone and
welcome if you like Fighting Chess you
have come to the right place Nasi let's
take a look at this graphic it says it
all I mean this ladies have been
fighting until the end in the fourth
rounds the decisive results were 80
percent exactly unprecedented it's
really been a marvelous tournament and
what will round three bring well you
know the standings are going to be
excited let's take a look at that let's
take a look we have a soul litter after
round two Alexandra costing you she won
both her games then closely following
with one and a half points
and two Americans are in a crush and
that's quite the chasing pack with 50
percent Hurricane Valley Elizabeth pets
and gunai mamazada and tell us about the
format for the Karen's cup we have a 10
player round robin tournament with no
draw offers right the time control is 90
minutes for first 40 moves 30 minutes
rest of the game and 30 second increment
from move one and our schedule the
players will be playing total of nine
rounds and today they'll begin round
three on Thursday June 8th they're going
to have a rest day and and four rounds
to the finish a Sprint to the finish and
we're very very lucky to have in studio
umera and yesterday Almera there was a
moment that was I think for the history
books it was that game between Bella
and Anna Anna's completely winning she's
two pawns up her opponent could have
resigned at any moment we would have all
understood but Anna set the moment for
her opponent to save the game tell us
what happened indeed yes sir and kudos
to Nazi for spots in that move yesterday
but let's have a look at this position
so
is having white pieces he's completely
winning she can make any move but she
starts with a small inaccuracy right
here she plays this move F5 check okay
you don't miss anything yet but after
King H4 please have a look at this
position you know the king doesn't have
any Square where to go so because the
Rook cuts the third rung and it sets up
a lot of stalemate idea
here anna proceeds to play carelessly
and she makes this careless move and the
impossible happened her opponent though
being two pawns down can make a draw in
this position so she can sacrifice The
Rook on A3 it's an incredible idea but
if you take this Rook
that's tell me you know I cannot make a
move on the touch screen so let's say
what if you don't take the rook and you
move your Rook to B1 but then the
sacrifice is continuous and you will
have to take the Rook otherwise I will
take the pawn on before so after Rook B3
the game could have ended in a draw so
let's have a look at Anna's reaction
when she saw this position in the studio
yesterday
welcome Anna
I think we had the reveal
because I can't believe it yes and I
just saw the move aruke 3 I showed her
because hopefully she didn't see it
during the game I didn't see of course I
would play something
but even after he played yes
I was I was looking at all kinds of
stalemates and here like in this moment
and I saw this idea as like
oh well congratulations
[Laughter]
well that was such a unique moment and
yes sir what do you think Canada push
her luck any further today
absolutely Almira I mean you you're a
competitor you know what it's like to
have the wind in your sails you get a
gift like that you feel on top of the
Wilderness yes and uh
she's feeling good today I'm sure
absolutely well let's see if she
pressures her luck set the stage for our
viewers and tell them what they can
expect for today's parents let's take a
look at round three pairings we have an
all Indian matchup Toronto Valley
against coneru then Mama Zara will be
facing the tournament leader Alexander
Augustine with a game to watch for sure
and as a townski will be playing
Elizabeth pets Abdul Malik against Hotel
Nashville and Irina crash against Anna
Technica for me that's really a kind of
a marquee matchup that uh Ty for second
is the two players there the the
fighting has been Fierce what are they
fighting for they're fighting for a lot
of money there's total of hundred and
eighty thousand dollars in prizes the
first place winners going to win forty
five thousand dollars second place
thirty five thousand third twenty five
thousand generous price fund all the way
down to 10th and final position six
thousand dollars everybody's gonna go
home a winner but especially our sons
this chess has just been wonderful to
call as we get ready for round three the
players are taking their seats here in
the Beautiful World Chess Hall of Fame
where they're playing right across the
street from us and we're here at the St
Louis chess club in Scholastic Center as
we see
our defending Champion going up against
hereka
this rival I would say our biggest rival
and also her teammate I'm sure they
played many olympiads together exactly
now
for them uh this is a rivalry that is
intense a lot of people wrongly think oh
they're they're friends they'll make a a
a a a Sisterhood draw no no no no no
when I was playing my American Rivals
overseas you know we'd be hitting the
fences yeah so they may be friends but
they're not friends of the board not at
the chess board as we see Arena crash
getting uh wanted by the chief Arbiter
shoot it and this is a special wand uh
electronic for the possibility of an ear
yes and I have experience with that I
like to wear earrings so every time I
would come at the American Cup right it
would yes I had to take my earrings
off just to make sure that it was just
earrings making the sound Rex getting a
hug what's going on here Rex you just
happened to be in the standing in the
way oh really so a little uh being
nice Serena tied Force second now the
american ladies come into this
competition actually is the lowest seeds
but that's not stopping them from
getting a on the podium they've had an
amazing start both of them one and a
half out of two and Almira they the
young lady Brunei she got a gift from
Bella in the first round but yesterday
uh Elizabeth played very very well
against her she's going up against
Alexandra how's she feeling
I think you know yesterday Guinea had a
very difficult game and I will use the
word demolished you know I think she was
demolished by Elizabeth she played
almost perfectly and today will be a
real test for gennai I think because
well she didn't really play the first
game and she's playing against the
tournament leader uh I think Alexandra
will play any game for a win first
and in their head-to-head matchup
wow Alexandra has been in her every time
for 14 times that is a serious adoption
Omer yes this is such an impressive
aggressive scores so wow okay do you
have 14-0 against anyone
um no right yes sir no not even I don't
think it's not even close no no no no no
no no no no no no and we do have opening
E4 and again uh Alexandra to oh start
she had the white pieces in her opening
games so
uh sometimes you think to yourself you
know 2-0 let's let's go for Perfection
but she's not playing anything razor
yeah she usually plays Sicilian right
she's a very aggressive player but she
has chosen E4 E5 for today no Berlin
but uh classical A7 A6 to be honest
purely from a mathematical point of view
the numbers are against Alexander
because at some point you know gunai has
to score exactly right yeah I mean 14.
oh my goodness well I mean again uh gune
is 22 years old so it's quite clear that
Alexander has been playing against her
since she's been a teen but that is
really an overwhelming score I I wow
14-0 no I couldn't even imagine good
point by way mathematically you know at
some point the bleeding stops right will
it be today you stop the bleeding with a
draw first right that's the that that's
the advice our coaches always gave us uh
Bishop E7 okay in this moment you also
have the exchange rui Lopez and also
what we call the exchange rui Lopez
deferred with Bishop take C6 I've never
really understood the Deferred as
opposed to the straightforward stuff but
we uh playing Bishop B3 I noticed in
Stavanger the tournament that's being
taking place in Norway a lot of the
players are in two of the games I want
to say
Marshall with a c2c3 and a D7 D5 we'll
see if uh
way white can avoid right it's called
anti-marshall with a2a4 yes and that was
really featured quite a number of world
championship matches the Marshall a good
drawing weapon so the anti-martial
a2a4 but Amira jumping over to you what
has caught your eye as we open round
three
well I think there is a very sharp game
in perspective between Irina crush and
Nana jagnitzi well let's have a look at
the opening from the very start
um
Irina started with D4 so
and here Nana was is opting for a very
interesting structure because this is
not Queen's Gambit but I think she
wanted to head for a naughty boom you
know structure and the arena didn't
allow it you know which can appear after
Knight F3 let's say and then Knight F6
and but Irina didn't allow it she played
a very sharp move E4 here
so
94 Bishop B4 check a lot of games have
been played on the top level and this
variation Bishop D2 is the main move and
it allows you know the pound sacrifice
so I can take on D4 then
white can take on B4 Queen A4
one of the recent games were played
between Anish giri and Magnus Carlson so
what do you do here you can play 92 or
Bishop but Bishop E2
allows another Pawn sacrifice but you
have to be careful let's see what can
happen after Queen G2
you can threaten mate and leave The Rook
here you know after Queen D6 it's not
sure for me how are you going to
you know to continue you can play 97
and let me have a look yes you can make
a long castle and just leave the room
here you know wow so this is a very
possible variation but I don't think
that nana will go for Queen jitu even if
she takes the pound and after Queen A4
let's say white will play
um
yes now I think the most important
continuation is a very strange looking
move Knight A6 but I am asking this
bishop a question so you have to move
your bishop and you can play
um
Bishop A5 first of all and you're
threatening mate on d8 but you have a
lot of other options in this position so
what I like about the Arena's
preparation is that she
asks her opponents about a lot of
questions so in already in the opening
Nana jagnitzel has a huge choice and
this can lead to a mistake all right uh
Bishop A5 was put on the board after 96.
we have already a few years okay
threatening Queen d8 Checkmate uh Nana
blocked the threat of Queen d8 mate
attacking the bishop Queen came to D6
inviting Queen takes G2 as well as
um B takes A5 now the thing why did
Arena Play Bishop A5 she wanted to
induce the move B6 so that any time you
play Queen takes G2 the pawn on C6 is
really weak so that Bishop F3 and oopsie
Daisy you're busted
capturing on A5 runs into another
problem now with the Rook battery we're
threatening Checkmate we don't have a
convenient way
F6 and run with the King whoa F6
and he still has Bishop after Ronaldo's
Quincy for with the check this is such a
sharp line I remember I would say that
uh somebody's fallen for it I don't know
who's trapping who I was analyzing this
maybe 10 years ago with the black pieces
I really wanted to take the pawn right
but I was like no no it's too scary just
never go for this Nana declined the
bishop instead she played Bishop D7
anticipating that after uh Rook to D1 or
castles she'll have either Rook d8 or
Knight F6 defending uh the bishop the
bishop actually after Bishop D7 the
bishop dropped back sensibly uh to at
the C3 uh attacking and did nana stop I
thought yes then I was thinking now okay
a strange place to pause right because
this is all very uh forcing F7 F6 uh was
her choice so now I think idea is if
Irina Castle is long no Anna's also
going to Castle exactly putting her King
also tucking her King over to the queen
side this night on A6 a little offsides
but because it can bounce either to the
C5 or C7 Square she's happy by the way
kind of funnily and not the Knight also
might come to H6 and to F5 what other
games caught your eye uh let's see I
actually am fascinated with this one
this one yeah definitely the pawn
sacrifice I think it's just called the
slav uh Gambit for white is that Samus
law semi sloth Gambit I think so
but let's go to Anna's game against
Elizabeth pets okay they're still very
early in the opening just wanted to show
that they have the ninja themsel with a
classical ninja Queen C2 D5 a2a3 takes
takes and it's just funny so whenever I
prepare against Donna with the black
pieces yes I think every game I've
played ninto against her and she has
hundreds of games but she but she still
takes so much time in the opening to
decide which line she's going to play
but today she's just playing quite quite
fast so she's prepared uh
the meaning of the C5 is not the most
common movie I wanted to say I have
reached this position in my practice as
white and numerous times I'm familiar
with Cal uh pardon me I wanted to say
castles as well as D5 takes E4 how about
Knight E4
I think that's quite sharp line yeah 94
uh actually I'm familiar with the line
but not in my practice my opponents have
not played Knight E4 against me I
noticed that in Stavanger a tournament I
reference that's going on today right
now uh Anish giri had played that
in I think I want to say the Armageddon
game but Queen takes E3 I always thought
that this move you shouldn't play you
should not play the idea is that I'm
getting the dark I've won the dark
squared Bishop but at the moment really
the best Square for my dark Square
Bishop is Bishop G5 and sometimes you
can hunt it down and Chase it and
capture it but if you play the move C5
you're actually encouraging my Bishop to
come on the long diagonal and a move
like D4 takes C5 so that I can play
excuse me my arrows are a little bit
off-kilter today B4 and Bishop B2 well
now my Bishop is really working so the
move C5 to me is a lesser move
not it's more a modern computer line is
it and the idea is that if you take on
C5 that's what I'm gonna do black plays
immediately D4 okay and my queen has to
retreat and then E5 so black says
goodbye to the opponents the fire is not
taking back anything like for example B4
you're not getting the pawn back but
you've got they have a good Center uh
yeah and uh Amira I wanted to ask you
about that good Center is this uh Nasi
says that the chess engines uh consider
this position uh theoretically playable
statistically speaking how are the
players doing oh I see you've got Knight
E4 on the board yes yes I wanted just to
show you what could have happened
because there is a small line which I
like very much which offers black uh a
very interesting play here a bit in the
spirit of the position that we have now
so black could have played C5 here did
the xc5 Knight C6 developing all the
pieces especially that uh White's Queen
was moving for several times already so
here and Bishop F5 you can see this you
know creating a very unusual situation
B4 is the move here so castle and I was
thinking okay what is happening after
Knight G3 because this is a very nice
idea but then you simply sacrifice The
Rook you know and this that's why I
think that's you know this variation is
not playable for for black and you know
you for the moment your play Rook down
but look at your pieces yeah the knight
from each one is now ever making back so
that's why just a few moves more
normally you play castle Bishop B2
rookie 8 Rook D1 and I tried Knight G3
here as well but here you have Queen C3
so I think I like this variation very
much I don't know why Elizabeth didn't
go for this line but maybe she
considered it to be way too sharp to
play today so she went for the line that
we have in the game C5 yeah yes C5 just
let me
fish
five
so we were yesterday wants to take on C5
oh yes I do yes another option is you
can take on D5 first so C5 okay well you
can take GTX C5 of course
right and then the move is D4 right then
yes I remember
Queen just three years very important
resource yes but we we don't have too
many recent games I think because yes uh
Black's position and especially black
center offers uh like a very nice well
play so you can play Knight C6 here is
that a second part yes it's a sacrifice
you can sacrifice another bounce or
after there was a one game which was
played by karpov with white and he lost
against the French player uh eduaroma so
it should be careful here let's say
queen H6 and what is uh Black's ideas so
almost like in the French defense where
you sacrifice the pound on G7 yes you
have a lot of activity for sacrifice two
pounds and this computer you know this
position with two pounds down computer
evaluates is equal so wow and in their
head-to-head matchups
I know I would expect I would have more
games amongst between them yeah they've
been either both players uh you would
think so only seven games but two wins
no wins for Elizabeth and by the way uh
our production team uh does want to
reassure us that that 14-0 score that we
saw between Alexandra and gunay includes
all games Blitz rapid classical that's
not a 14-0 classical score because
otherwise you know like I would be
complaining to the organizer I don't
want this player in any word any
classical tournament I'm playing in so
yes that their their score of all wins
I just saw a long long move there by aha
oh it it is the Marshall yes they did go
into the Marshall I'm referring to the
game between Alexandra they're still in
theory yes so it did uh from the opening
Knight takes E5 and I take C5 the
Marshall Gambit fantastic fantastic
story behind the Marshall Gambit of
course it was Frank Marshall
who discovered the line and Frank
Marshall would go to bed at night and he
would put a little notebook with a
little pencil beside his bed reading
table because sometimes he dreamed about
Chess and he wanted when he woke up to
write whatever he dreamed about and he
dreamed about the Marshall Gambit so he
wrote it down in his notebook
he woke up he saw what he had written he
spent the next 10 years
preparing to play it against capablanca
the Marshall Gambit he waited 10 years
prepped everything
unbelievably
Kappa walked into his preparation
actually happened it actually happened
capablanca over the board refuted
his preparation in capablanca won the
game
after Marshall's discovery all the
players gathered around and here and
there and here and there improvements
were found and today it's considered one
of Black's best defenses uh incredible
he came up with it in his sleep in his
dreams and again I boy I keep
referencing the the tournament uh
Stavanger tournament as uh again this
position has appeared there also I
thought in the past in this particular
position that Bishop D2 was also a
common way that white handled this
position takes takes Knight D2 Queen E1
and this is where I was saying that long
move Alexandra Queenie wanchak the
Knight dropped back to F1 the bishop
dropped back and gunay is thinking again
as you were about to say this is all
still on theoretical ground yes there's
still Theory there are a couple of games
coming up in the database civil replace
this a lot with black actually yes he
does Lavon aronian Mickey Adams John
Nunn oh great yeah all great players uh
Peter laco uh use the Marshall uh Gambit
and in this position what is the
theoretical continuation G3 I think but
we can ask alamira let's do it uh over
to you Almira
how was how is white supposed to
untangle his pieces the the back rank
pin is a is bothersome yes it's a highly
theoretical position I wanted to show
you first what can happen if White
is greedy and takes another poems yes
please of course black is counting on
the compensation here and
a very precise move fruit it has to be
done here for example
well there is a threat of Bishop taking
H2 and I asked myself okay what is
happening after queen of three I simply
Retreat my queen and I protect all the
pieces so the computer says that this
position is absolutely lost after Bishop
D3 you know and there is nothing to do
right
of course so you have to be aware of
what the Tactical ideas here of course
you don't have to take the second pound
so
G3 is a very
um
a precise move once again because first
of all you will you have to make at
least to have one square for your king
and here after Rook 8 there is a very
interesting move and which answer your
question how to entangle the pieces it's
Bishop D1
a very unusual move yes but now your
Bishop on C1 is free to go
considered to be slightly better for uh
for white here but I think that black
has always sufficient play you know in
order to keep the balance Amira I'm a
pond grubber if you go back could you
please show me that variation again
Bishop takes D5
you take my Bishop I take the pawn give
me a rook you go rook d8 and now I hit
you with my surprise move Bishop G5 I'm
attacking your queen with my Rook go
ahead take my Rook I'll take your Rook
I'm a happy camper well there are a few
games here but there was just uh
verifying if you are not sleeping
uh that's the best move in the position
okay so I have to take the Rook yeah I
will take the Rook on the eight and now
you know I can also take an H2 oh no yes
because you have to take whatever right
yes
one opposite color yes and the bishop of
the opposite color offers uh black very
good drawing chances now here now for
our audience this is really an important
moment if you look at our mirrors
position after Bishop H2 King H2
white could check made in one
if Queen takes Bishop Queen takes d8 was
uh allowed I mean it would be Checkmate
just pointing out yeah that
extraordinary idea
we can continue a little bit of course
yes Queen A8 is a very good move but I
will simply play H6 and if you take on
A6 or if you give me a check I can
always take on F2 on D3 and I think that
it's an easy yeah it will be easiest to
hold this position with luck thank you
for that I like the move Bishop D1
prepping Bishop D2 let's catch up do you
want your three in one Bishop but then
your opinion your other Vision exactly
by the way G2 G3 by gune she shows that
she's theoretically prepared and G2 G3
by the way the other thing about the
Marshall Gambit it's one of those
variations that can go incredibly deep
like your prep operation has to be 20 25
moves and sometimes even longer again
one of my absolute favorite stories was
Peter spidler was a coach for Vladimir
kramnik and they were playing the world
championship match against Peter laco
and Vladimir said I've got this great
idea in the Marshall go ahead and check
it with the engines and to make sure
it's sound and I take no risks Peter
says I'm on it there's one massively
important matching Cricket that Peter
goes to watch
he doesn't have time to check it on his
computer but Pottermore goes into the
game and his preparation was a force
loss
somehow Peter kept his job it was like
the most amazing you have to be a very
very good friend I understand I
understand who won the cricket match as
Vladimir kramnik G2 G3 statistically uh
oh sorry you've got a different position
on the board uh Amira yes I just wanted
to draw your attention that and this is
the position yes in the game between
Harry cardrono Valley and hampi conero
and well at the beginning of the round
you said that harika will be quite
ambitious with the white pieces because
it offers her this unique opportunity
also to uh well to play against her
rival and maybe to prove that she is a
worthy opponent
right the moment I say this is going to
be the the the the big big fight yes and
please have a look at their Club box
wow Panero has only spent five minutes
and uh he car he can
harika has gained time and I seem to
recall I think this is a game that
Fabiano maybe Wesley also has played
this is theory and you can you you can
see the clock times that the players are
very very familiar literally they've
zipped right past the middle game right
past the opening right into ending and
I'm gonna guess let me guess triple
zeros Almera yes quadruple zero
quadruple
I see so uh this game's going heading
for a draw well to be home honest I I do
know
what this position and you have to be
precise with black in order to make a
draw here of course because H4 is the
move which was played in the game
between Wesley so and Magnus Carlsen but
there was another president there was
the game between uh Sergey karakin and
veget so we did lost this game with
black and so let me just show you what
happened in this game I think it was
Bishop A6 that's an important move to
keep the B7 Square under guard so Bishop
B6 then Rook B3 and I think that here
widgets thought that he is making a
simple draw here you know with no that I
know that's actually the move yes and
let me just check what was the the
symbol there was a mistake yes that was
the game and we just saw that it will be
an easy draw and actually Bishop B2 is a
very precise move to make to make a draw
here and Sergey karenkin went on to win
this game because it allows this Rook C3
you know and this end game is becoming
very unpleasant the computer shows
already a slight slight Advantage for
for white because He suggests this move
Bishop B2 now so he wants you to play
this end game upon down so you need to
be very precise and you need to make
bishop E2 here immediately as as Magnus
Carlson played so this move guarantees
you a draw
interesting uh very important subtleties
even in the endings Bishop A6 and Bishop
E2 with all the decisive games from the
kieran's cup we thought it would be kind
of fun to take a look at the live rating
uh changes and here we see them as our
number one top seed it's losing some
writing points she certainly is however
look at Carson looks like rating Change
Plus 10.4 after two games nice Ah that's
very nice and also on as a tank plus 9.3
yes I mean I crash the american ladies
are doing amazing and unfortunately for
some players Bella and John Sayer not
not going so well but they have seven
games to make up the rating absolutely
yes they do and actually we haven't seen
that game yet today so let's take a look
exactly against Bella it's board one yep
at the very very top and this looks like
an interesting maneuvering game where
did this come Italian game with the two
knights Knight F6 Bishop E7 Knight C3
okay almost a
philadelph76 bishop G4 okay that's a
little bit of a surprise just giving up
the two Bishops so quickly did not uh
want to see Bishop H5 G4 Bishop takes
Queen takes knight uh knight uh of
course threatening both C2 Pawn as well
as the F3 Queen
and well I can see from the
uh game list we have a database I guess
of a million games so we're we've got a
small database but this position's
actually uh been a guest in uh top level
chess uh two two Bishops I would think
that white has uh his normal her normal
opening Advantage no let's say the let's
say the engines there never played the
Italian game so I don't know how to
evaluate
well it's a closed position so the
Bishops are not you know stressing yet
Almera yes uh well actually I was so
surprised to find a game after H3 Bishop
H5 which was played by Jan Simmons I
think that you have a lot of stories to
tell us right about this incredible
player I just wanted to show you why
actually the bishop took on F3 before
because after after H3 Bishop H5 white
has this very aggressive move G4 right a
standard plan in this uh position in
this type of position so after Bishop G6
you know the computer already evaluates
the position is much much better for
white so you can con you can start with
playing Bishop B3 for example let's say
you make a castle I think that here your
plan with white is to play Queen Z2 and
then Castle long and attack your
opponents you should avoid this position
at any cost
and that's why uh black took on F3
so and of course you're winning the
tempo so Queen takes a three uh Knight
D4 Queen D1 C6 is a very important
inclusion here Bishop A2
castle castle and 96. so I have a few
games here because one of the most
interesting moves and the move which was
played
a few times is Knight E2 here so I have
a game between Jessica and kadubov and
it's quite recent so here black can
start with D5 already and this position
is about equal okay intriguing uh Nasi
talked to me about the psycho the
psychological side of this matchup
because both players enormously
successful throughout their whole career
both of the players starting with two
losses and once in my life once in my
career I lost three games in a row and I
thought the world turned upside down
like physics stopped nothing made sense
losing two games in a row you're
wobbling
what's going on with psychologically of
these two players they don't want to
lose a third but they want to win right
so when you lose first game you know it
happens it happens now when you lose
second game now you're angry and hurt
and you're confident suffers oh exactly
but like you said if you lose a third
like your world is ending exactly and I
think both of those players the thing is
they're both such strong Grandmasters
Bella had a very very unfortunate start
right but jean Saya actually had long
games and she lost very fighting games
yeah because her opponent played well
and Bella's case jet lag blunder the uh
of the first game she loses a piece it
happens uh she gets over it yesterday
you know she makes this horrible move
goes into an ending two pawns down but
then doesn't grab a gift that was
offered so for her that she didn't see
it even after the game because it's very
hard to recover from that that you
missed a stalemate opportunity but
that's the thing I think today
especially after the game uh the players
want to run to their hotel rooms and
check their preparation did they did
they play their opening precisely well
did their opponent do something as well
as to check their game so I'm sure but
you might have not gone all the way to
the end game really she might have said
oh I was lost that's what I do that's
what I do dude in the tournament I don't
analyze my own games because if I see
something like that I'm not recovering
from that
okay but I think they will try to start
a new tournament today right like forget
about the last two games let's begin
again and that's the tough part let's
forget about the past it didn't count it
doesn't matter let's let's uh talk about
this game that getting in that mind
frame
that's what a champion does it's not so
easy trust me 96 very experienced player
I'm sure they know how to come back from
absolutely just jumping into uh the the
game between our two players two of the
three players who tied for second uh
Arena crush and Nana uh when we left it
it was this theoretical dispute Queen is
on D6 we've just seen the move F7 F6
Knight F3 Knight H6 kind of as
advertised the Knight is looking to push
the queen away since you haven't
committed your king to the to the queen
side Nana's being flexible as well
Knight D2 please please help yourself
take my Pawn so that I can play Bishop
F3 maybe even actually that's actually a
cool idea how remember when she played
Bishop A5 in order to provoke V6 so that
the C6 Bond could be weak how do you
like these apples they should check so
that I promote the this fun to be weak
and now when I come back uh that would
have been fun uh Nana said no no I got
you I see that Queen F5 Queen A3 Knight
Bishop are we still uh Almera are we
still in uh theoretically tried and
tested Waters yes I have one recent game
actually so in this position black
Castle after Bishop D4 okay and which
allows white to take on C5 okay to win
back her Palm yes and how certain
Grandmasters would say Pawn structure
their opponent what does it mean it's a
new term in the church jargon which
means that they destroy your Pawn
structure so you have to take on C5 but
and by the way we do a very very precise
I want to say get a draw between harika
and humpy as they both tested one
another's uh opening knowledge and guess
what
they knew they both knew they both knew
the variation and a draw and by the way
did I yeah it looked 132 for harika she
had more time at the end of the game but
humpy was just attached slower
so that you had to be more careful yeah
and she she wanted to be precise so our
first result of around three is a draw
and a very unusual guest in the kieran's
cup a draw yes and if we follow the
trend all the other games will be
decisive today exactly exactly sorry I'm
there you were talking about this new
concept of
Pawn structure being damaged yes exactly
just
one small digression here what happens
if you take with the greens if I've done
simply Quincy five bit B takes C5 and
well you have Knight T4 you can win the
pawn of course you can even Castle long
in this complex middle game and then
well win the pound on C5 so you're
almost forced to take with the bone on
C5 and we're still following the game
between streamavicious and Kalik stain
so after B takes C5 the computer thinks
that white is slightly better of course
I think that due to this slightly
weak bone structure right and so well
you can Castle
here and black has a few options so I
was thinking that you know you have this
wonderful Square on D4 and this can also
justify you know your knight on uh H6 so
maybe you can play uh Queen A5 with the
idea of playing Knight F5 and Knight D4
so sure this is a very interesting plan
for black in this position after Queen
F5 if you attack the the bishop on E2 so
rookie one you have to defend it so here
I you know I didn't know what to do
because if you Retreat Queen C7 then I
maybe can like can I take on C5 what do
you think I have to ask the computer
here because I was trying to analyze
this position myself but I'm not sure
yes you can take on C5 so it's it's
quite a valid option so maybe another
has to find a way to make it work better
you know native five and uh
94 but I think it's a very interesting
plan
thank you uh Amira by the way we asked
our audience yesterday or maybe even was
the day before to help us name the
computer and there was not
deep not so deep not so deep blue
uh we also had Hal 50 a play on Hal 2000
from uh Kubrick Judith that was pretty
good and uh today you at the start of
the show offered Yoda where so we we've
got to come up with something and uh
when we ask Yoda or the chess engine
Judith did we like Judith we weren't we
did but we have to ask Judith yeah and
on that note how does our audience join
the conversation you can send us it's
using hashtag Karen's cup or you're also
welcome to send us your questions and
comments on YouTube and twitch St Louis
chess club Channel
and our social media manager Sabina
fuchsia will send us your questions
absolutely keep us on our toes everybody
as around
three uh started well with a fizzle a
draw in the all Indian derby
um what
is culture I uh Arena Crush we think is
slightly better she can win back her
Pawn Yeah Yeah so can you tell me with
Yoda's voice Arena crashes slightly
better
uh
uh boy I gotta get into the in the
character uh yeah I gotta get
uh
so
tactic
no I can't do it you want tactic
yes we need we need we need exactly
sharp something something sharp Bishop
something before that was awful I I'll
do better yeah and then trains are in
the break yeah next uh uh next go round
uh I'd like us to go back to the game of
Alexandra because theoretically I was
very curious okay now we know that uh G3
deals with all of those issues
um now I'm ready to play Bishop takes D5
right and I don't have to suffer the
consequences of Bishop takes H2 that
variation that Almera was showing so in
my mind I was thinking I guess H7 H6 or
something like that so I was a bit
surprised by the move B4 but this turns
out to be theoretical and Amira why
can't I take the pawn now
well I was anticipating your question
please have a look at the position I
can't believe I'm that obvious I hate
being obvious I'm clearly you know
established that there is a part a
pattern you know so you have to be less
predictable otherwise on the poker table
you will lose everything I'm sure I'm
sure you will you will destroy me I'm
the poker team so let's have a look uh
why can't you take of course you can't
take with a pound on D5 another
move Bishop G5 here so that's the same
position that's the same thematic idea
so you have the conclusion of G3 which
is a big benefit for white no more
Bishop takes H2 for you young lady yes
but here surprisingly you can make a
very calm move Bishop f8 because you
know the weaknesses of your uh pounds
you're on the on the queen side you know
once again guarantee is black sufficient
counter play here so
have a look at the position you know and
then the variations zero zero okay of
course computers suggest this move
Bishop A5 because you need to protect
the bone on C3 also this is very weak
and G3 weakens white squares here so
there is a possible mating net right so
we still I have a game here but which is
quite ancient and what I think that
Alexandra has uh uh and she understood
While She Was preparing against her
opponent that there is a weak spot in
her opening repertoire that's why she's
targeting exactly this line that's why
she played before okay in this position
and if her opponent is over ambitious
with white she has some counter chances
and she can she may even win the game so
I think this explains the choice of
before but why not see for them sure
Drive the night back you you throw the
Knight back with the temple so Knight F6
here and uh well why not to grab another
phone yes sir ah now we're talking
you know and I think that this opening
illustrates perfectly the Modern Trend
of of
opening choice that you are going for
the initiative at any cost and I like
this very much because the games are
very sharp your opponent is faced with a
lot of difficult decisions and he's
facing them on every move right so let's
have a look after uh Rook date Queen B6
was played there numbers of games here
and I think that maybe if this line will
appear on the board well Alexandra will
come up with the novelty
but there is another move which is
Knight C7 also after C4 sorry here after
67 Knight C7 all right but okay it was
played mostly by amateur players so here
what's the idea yes because your knight
protects the Rook on it of course and so
now the position is completely lost for
white after 56 yes Bishop takes D3 and
well you will have to play Queen G2 and
after Rook 8 bring in your last piece
into the play you know the position is
completely hopeless for white exactly
because you will never entangle your
pieces and Amira I was Charmed by the
position after C4 Knight C7 or you drive
the Knight back and that line where you
showed Bishop D1 and then you want to
play Bishop D2 if you can drive the
queen back your Pawn up after all is
this theoretically uh played Yes
actually it's the strongest move in this
position and now that you have you've
you've grasped the essence of the
position you know that this is the move
that you're going to make when you're
given the opportunity
but Knights of seven that's why I like
this move allows 96 and even though
you're a pound down you can jump to D4
you know and
I like this position for a black person
wow nothing special Essence I like to
think I I understand the soul of chess
the essence okay I'll go with that I'll
go with the soul of chess ponzer the
soul of Chess
Alexandra is so well prepared she has
one hour and 35 minutes on the clock wow
that's uh she's already 35 minutes ahead
of her opponent okay so it's like five
level preparation exactly uh when I find
myself in those situations where I've
clearly been outplayed in the opening
out prepared I want to say outplayed is
the wrong word out prepared
that actually gets me nervous as if I'm
down on the clock I just feel like oh oh
you know now I start looking for ways of
maybe exiting apologizing to everybody
uh for my poor uh preparation B5 B4 and
white is challenged because C4 feels
like the right move driving the Knight
to C7 Bishop D1 feels like you know
because I'm sitting here saying you know
this queen is really really annoying to
me uh I'd even be thinking about
exchange sacrifices frankly a move like
uh
yeah just because I hate I feel I have
this physical feeling like I'm being
tied up and I hate that feeling so even
anything that solves the background pin
I find attractive but Almera we have
guests in studio over to you
yes yes sir we have harika in our studio
welcome to Saint Louis haircut so today
the game was not uh about fireworks
probably I wanted to ask you how
difficult it is for you to play against
hampi
uh I think especially these days so we
are playing with the same team in the
Indian channel for India so of course we
had we have some connect and it is
slightly difficult but of course we are
playing in serious tournaments a game is
a game so were you checking uh her
preparation today I think that well
judging by the clock you knew the
position perfectly you even had more
time than when you started so uh no
actually I uh I mean I decided to play
Scotch but this model maybe I thought
she wouldn't Place uh with me like in
the classical game she never played so I
didn't prepare and when she played it uh
okay special I didn't prepare much
because yesterday I was like really
upset after a long game and a good game
I uh it was such a hard luck that this
root k6 exists and I I had like some
thousand ways to draw so I decided I'm
not like preparing much and I only saw
like maybe one two hours sleep keep it
and I decided if it comes okay I'll play
something I played already like I played
this um I mean I don't know 100 games
online so okay I decided okay if it's
solid if solid black knows everything
Etc but so this game is an opening
surprise today
uh I won't say surprise uh but yes like
I gave this least importance
and I played this with black also I like
um I had draw I think three years back
with plank but I play many games in this
online I played so okay I didn't expect
too much and I didn't want to do
anything new I just played something I
know very well and if it's a draw Etc
and well you talked about the game uh
that you lost yesterday who helps you in
those difficult situations just myself I
think after all these years of
professional chess I think it's just we
have to help ourselves and uh yeah I
mean this just definitely motivates me
to play better chess because I think
I played good decent chess but this I
think the tiredness sometime overtook me
and like when I had best chances I
couldn't calculate accurately especially
because I'm coming from Grand Prix and
like I had a long game on the first day
I was like extremely tired and I think
somewhere I could see that white I
played bad so I forgive myself for that
and I'm moving on and I think today it's
in a way it's good for me that I'll get
some time to rest okay thank you I have
one last question for you because I've
seen there are a few players they have
some superstitions so is there any
absolutely rational Superstar that you
have no I have many but I don't want to
tell on camera and then everyone will
know but yes I have my knee from I think
from a childhood I had like many
superstitions I'm trying to get over
them and like you know to act mature but
still I have some but I wouldn't want to
tell this on camera to people so that
they know
well thank you very much and we wish you
all all the like you know that you need
for the rest of the tournament thank you
uh Amir thank you Eureka actually I did
too a Superstition that I had I always
loved pens I found myself fascinated by
fountain pens and different pens I
really like the cross and the Montblanc
pens and I would literally go to the
shop and carefully choose a pen and if I
couldn't find the pen
before I went to the game I was
distraught like where's my lucky bed
I need my pen anything for my follow-up
question let's say you have a favorite
Lucky Pen right what happens after you
lose a game
down the stick I mean next County lucky
fan or not has got to go superstitions
no I don't have any never had any
actually
I never understood it right
right so I I know pretty much all the
players all my friends have
superstitions are you going to hurt some
that for example from the hotel there's
two elevators you can take down right
you come here and players will only pick
one until they lose a game and then they
switch to the other one right but
no superstitions for you no and back to
Almera uh for another guest
well today is a lucky day we're
welcoming the whole uh you know Indian
Olympic team welcome company
well you just made the draw and uh just
a second before I asked Eric a question
if she has any superstitions and there
was this discussion in the studio so do
you have any that you can share with us
uh well yeah sometimes I do use the same
pen if I win some games or the same
jacket or shirt it does happen often uh
if I lose something even though if it's
a new shirt I I just don't wear it for
the game
I think most of the chess players have
this type of issues but okay generally
speaking those just like you know just
emotional attachments but apart from
that
we just love to play chess yeah of
course
um well I've already forgot what I
wanted to tusky yes you are uh you're
our defending Champion uh well uh three
years have passed since the last edition
how does it feel to come back to some
place yeah it's really nice to be back
in America but you know we have been
more used to playing Europe so after
coming here there was a lot of jet lag
and tiredness I think
my game has also affected a lot and
uh probably from the if I look at my
games in the first and second rounds I'm
a bit disappointed with that I really
hope to come back
okay and um Elizabeth shared with us for
example that it's very important for her
to swim other place France what are you
doing at four in the morning push-ups
you know I just go for a walk okay just
for some fresh air okay thank you so
much well and hope that you come back
stronger thank you thank you indeed
uh yeah jet lag I have to say that in my
case it affected me my whole life and my
whenever I was going from Seattle and
usually I would go like something like
Seattle Denver Denver New York New York
London and then London Belgrade so it
was like a very very very long trip
usually I'd arrived like
two o'clock in the morning face plant
wake up by round three and uh what am I
doing
it's tough but uh jet lag today it's
still it as we've been watching
impacting the players I wanted to go to
the game uh of Bella's game for just a
moment because I did see this uh we did
see this yeah this Moon over night on C3
kind of looks good but from another
perspective what is white doing white
really wants to play the move f2f4 but
doesn't necessarily want to trade off
the dark Square Bishop so she preps the
move F4 with the move Knight E2 f4 on
the agenda and that's why we saw uh
allows black to play D5 precisely and I
think that that was a really well-timed
decision uh by Bella and after Knight G3
now defending the pawn but also you know
intimating that I'm getting ready to
step on the F5 Square well trading
Queens D takes D takes and I'm expecting
Queen takes D1 and even though uh we're
going into a kind of a two Bishops this
bishop on A2 is blocked BS you can
double the pawns but how are you going
to attack those
weak ponds even if they're doubled uh
like sorry I just they're quite species
you do okay good so let's let's start
shall we take Rook takes and let's let's
go
Rook uh to d8 so essentially what I'm
hoping to do is much like Alexandra's
game I want to be able to pin you on the
first ring Bishop D2 Bishop to D2 I want
to put my Bishop on C3 and go after one
of your sweet pods well well put okay so
uh I am going to attack uh the pawn on
on e4 F3 would be an ugly move
yeah yeah kind of right
but I think I have to play it uh because
you don't like Knight F5 you don't like
I like Knight F5 but after Bishop f8 I
thought
Bishop Knight F5 bishop f8 and what
exactly are you still have to play F3
yes one day uh you're going to play F3
uh what I wanted to say whether you
include the move Knight F5 or not I saw
your Bishop C3 and I wanted to head you
off at the pass
by uh by by trying to stop you from
playing Bishop C3 here again the
position uh semi-open uh a closed
position all the pawns are on the board
semi-open position only uh half only one
Pawn has been played by the way the
players have reached our position only
the choice was not Bishop to D2 Bishop
E3 which is okay a little bit more
ambitious but at the same time maybe
encouraging Bishops C5 and more
exchanges maybe more exchanges maybe
even night well Knight D4 might be an
overreach I was uh looking to play
Knight takes C2
um feels pretty balanced but maybe maybe
you share Nazis
feelings Almera that uh white with the
two Bishops should be a little bit
better
well what I don't like about Bella's
decision is that she defined the
structure at a very early stage I think
the whole idea of giving up to Bishops
that you have this powerful Center okay
and uh yes we will get the um
the position Bishop C5 has been played
by the way so she played GTX C4 D take
C4 takes on D1 takes on D1 and by the
way now we are uh out of theory which
was like yes because I wanted to show
you the game which was played between
ESPN coin dubov and dubov Daniel dubov
in this position he actually played G6 I
like this move because this Center is
very powerful so she and he keeps the
pressure in the center the Knight can no
longer go only five you know that rookie
one was played and a very simple move
Queen C7 so I I like this approach a bit
better because
um in why I
criticize this decision after d takes C4
detect C4 because my own experience
tells me that in this position uh well
black is playing only for two results
so I think only white can be in here or
there will be a draw suit
I was trying yes Bishop C5 here but
after Rook d8
Bishop D2
do we have no we have Bishop E3 on the
board yes we have Bishop B3 on the board
so let's see yes Bishop C5 is actually
the strongest move in this position
according to the computer and now the
position well he evaluates or this
position is equal because he doesn't
want to change the bishop here and He
suggests this move
so you see that
you provoke the bishop to a bad Square
so maybe
two was uh was it was more precise okay
and in their head-to-head matchups let's
see how these two uh have done very even
two wins for each and one draw okay very
uh balanced and as we get prepared for
our first break it's a good time to uh
go shopping let's check again
let's go to the World Chess Hall of Fame
Q Boutique and let's see what they have
as a special for us we have an engraved
Walnut wooden board and trust me when I
say these are very very beautiful boards
a very smooth finish on the surface this
absolutely stunning board makes the
perfect gift to someone else or even
yourself the board is crafted from
Walnut measuring 21 inches by 21 inches
with two and a quarter inch squares it
has unique grounded Corners displays the
laser-cut logos of the World Chess Hall
of Fame on the H1 and A8 squares and the
St Louis chess club on the A1 and H6
squares if you were here in town and you
could get the players to sign the boards
you'd be able to auction the boards for
thousands of dollars on eBay no it's a
it's it's great to get the player
signatures on the sets and then as we go
to break we asked the players who were
their biggest influence and influencers
in chess and here are their answers
[Music]
watch Hessler has mostly influenced your
chest career and why this is very
difficult question I am saying many
times I don't have just one role model I
admire people for different skills and
this is definitely all world champions
and especially like I'm a mother have
two kids and some chess players women
who combine just their chess career and
still playing like competitive chess
this is uh Pia crumlin who is still very
strong in her age and Monica sojko who
had like three kids and managing like
her chess career and another is
who became a GM in very like late age
like for around 40 I think she became a
GM
um you know I studied games from a lot
of good players and I definitely did
spend time on games collections you know
from the world champions and I feel like
from probably someone like botvanic
um in his Games Collection and you know
just learning a lot of Concepts from him
um opening things you know strategic
things I would say probably probably him
it's where I got my appreciation for big
Center and Bishop hair when I was in
little kid
um
starting from aliochine I think to
Casper for car park no kramnik and then
all of them
during this time they were very popular
I think it was Anatoly karpov I really
like to check his games with my watch
when I was young so probably yeah
probably it's just cup I'm a big fan of
Anatoly carpool and also Judith Polgar
so from my anger days I used to follow
their games and
their play has inspired me a lot
for Blanca and alohan was a ones that I
really loved their games and their style
casually was looking their games to
learn how to play chess and so and I
would call their names I think
kramnik or during my childhood days I
used to see a lot of his games and I
think somewhere I really like his style
and maybe not game wise but Judith
Polgar has a lot of influence on me as a
women player to be doing well in the men
to beat the strong man and like to be
there so definitely these two I think
are have influenced me a lot I was a fan
of Bobby pictures games when I was young
uh also Michael Tau was my favorite
chess player so I guess they influenced
my
style of play well honestly speaking my
dad is a grand master and he used to be
professional like when I was very young
so he had the deepest impact on me from
everybody because he taught me and my
brother at the early age how to play and
of course he went with us to tournaments
and he had been my teacher up till 16
before I actually met other trainers I
wish I wish I had such a player you know
it's such an influencer Mentor in a way
because
when I was growing up I wasn't really
excited about Chess lines and like moves
and champions in a way I was excited
about the psychological part of a battle
and I was I like to
um to read chess books I mean from Jazz
Champions but not about chess moves or
openings or middle games nothing about
that but rather about psychological
preparation and about how games like uh
went and how they prepared and what went
wrong if they lost so I didn't have a
chess Mentor in a way and I feel that
I'm lacking this like information right
now because definitely like your
youngest years are the best in order to
consume and be able to learn certain
material but of course it's never too
late with the chat book and what I'm
trying to do right now is to to learn
from those great chess Champions and
their games because well you need to
know history in order not to make the
same mistake in your own games
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
laughs
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our results so far we had one drop
between Toronto Valley and conero
another four games are still going
exactly and exciting games they are and
most in particular is Alexander Uh
custom York uh Alexandra started with
2-0 and she she essayed the Marshall
Gambit today and good ain't played this
move Bishop A4 which hey I wanna I wanna
take this Pawn on C6 it will undermine
the night on D5 uh kick the stools out
from under the Knight Bishop takes C6 on
tap and also it'll attack The Rook so
this was a novel novelty Alexandra spent
20 minutes did you say yes and she
decided to challenge her opponent and
say execute your threat to six Bond
Hangin yes execute your thread and as we
were coming on uh the air we were saying
oh my gosh how is it going to happen
what's going to happen B take C3 Bishop
takes season I was expecting simple Rook
C8 right
but now I was expecting Rook seed before
B takes yes sorry you you thought that
Alexander was just simply going to
defend but Pawn she didn't she took and
we were looking at Bishop takes C6 but I
think our attention was uh on the Move
night to before we say okay take my Rook
right take the Rook Bishop takes D3 give
me uh a back rank mate now here I could
go passive Queen G2 or I could say you
know like I'll give you uh some material
back after all I'm uh
you know uh should I go Queen but then
we were getting bogged down we were
saying well Queen G2 Knight C2 and what
is going on and guess what that's why we
have Judith and Almera in studio uh the
Beast what is the Beast telling us about
this crazy position
um well here I have the position on the
board and actually after night situ here
uh the position is simply equal as usual
and if you try to save your Rook because
I will take the Rook on A1 and you will
play Rook B1 then after Knight D4 black
is already winning because there are too
many threats you know I'm threatening
your Rook there are a lot of checks and
so um
let's say if you try to save your rook
in this way then you will simply give
check
King H1
computer even goes farther he plays C2
first so it simply shows how black
dominates being a rook down I think it's
it's an incredible position so what can
you do here let's say H4 minus six while
down a road
and like after a king age too he takes
he takes some F1 okay this is dominant
simply hopeless yes so I think that here
and what surprised me after Bishop B
takes C3 actually computer thinks that
white is already winning so I wouldn't
trust it
till until I see the variation on the
board because very often especially in
the Marshall computer changes its
evaluation
at the very last you know move so I want
to
um
wait for Alexandra to show her
preparation but after Bishop A4 B takes
C3 the evaluation is one plus 1.8 really
yes Bishop takes C6 night before of
course is the only move so
Bishop takes A8
Bishops takes D3
and here you know you will have to think
and to make the move H4 the asterisk
movie to give back the Knight and say
I'm not going to play Passive go ahead
and take the Knight and continue the
variation I'll mirror please yes I
wanted to show you that even here
computer thinks about the move C2 C2 yes
C2 well he can always take the Knight on
F1 but let's see what happens after
once again because it's still very
difficult for white to dismantle the
races used on the queen side here he
starts with A3 ah the Knight doesn't
have any Retreat squares okay yes and
you don't have a comfortable Square here
so you may try Bishop B2 but then after
Queen G2 you are forced to exchange
Queens so and this is maybe bishop jitu
is more precise and then 93
but I'm not sure that this is the
position that Alexander wants to play
today well that's strange because that
pawn on C2 would sure be terrifying me
once again this this line score as
dominating as it is is not just
classical games it does include I
suspect a fair amount of Blitz and Rapid
yeah yes 14 wins for Alexandra but
Lancaster said it includes rapid Blitz
and classical right so we'll see what
the classical matchup is but even that
exchange sacrifice Almira I wouldn't I
wouldn't be very confident in saying
yeah I'm much better with white because
as you were pointing out there was a
Pawn on a C2 in this variation where the
pawn goes to H4 Queen takes check King
up Pond goes to C2
A3 uh sorry I think A3 is the key move
to notice that Black Knight has nowhere
to go but even that we did get this
position with the Queens traded I mean
again I'm sitting there I see a Pawn on
my doorstep one one square from
Coronation uh am I confident would you
be confident like if if you gave me an
extra move and I play Bishop E5 you
might just be crying and saying oh my
gosh I'm gonna I'm gonna lose tonight
takes C1 Bishop D3 Bishop B2 so it's I
it feels like Tempo by tempo right only
the engine can be confident right
cold-bloodedly I see you have Bishop E4
Bishop E5 as a likely continuation
and it's it's plus three so it really
the engine really says white is doing
great
I'm surprised
I really am yes but you on the other
hand you have to calculate so many lines
and we've seen throughout the tournament
that uh very often this is the nature of
the human mistake because you very often
when you have the choice and the choice
is not obvious uh well that's how
players uh well make mistakes so I'm not
sure that gunai will play here
H4 not Queen G2 so we will have to see
all right we'll see how deep the
preparation of this novel approach in
the Marshall with Bishop A4 is a turn
our attention to two competitors who are
currently tied for second I'm referring
to Arena and Nana U.S number one against
Georgia's number one I was about to say
Isn't that cool number one versus number
I always love it when uh the two and top
players match up against none of the one
another we left this position really out
of a very topical Gambit
um these days in the semi-slav and Arena
just captured on C5 in order to win
Banker pawn and Amira was explaining
that it would be absolutely marvelous
from Black's point of view if she could
magically transfer her Knight to the D4
squared to get there she has to go
through F5 which kind of makes the move
Queen takes C5 understandable but the
engines were saying that this is
probably an imprecise this is an
imprecision and that black should
probably have started with uh B Tech C5
let's catch up with the players there
was a trade there goes the pawn here I
have a question for you you're going to
go take the pawn on C5 there's no
question you're going to do that you're
going to go night moves take the pawn
but you've got a choice you could go
through the B3 square or you could go
through the E4 Square
which one do you make and why
I mean Knight E4 looks better but I
think I understand why Arena chose
Knight B3 she wants to cover the P file
so there might be Rook B8 after Knight
E4 okay
and but once you have Knight on B3 after
Rook B8 you have a Tempo move long
Castle right that would defend upon on
B2 and then you're still taking the pawn
on C5 okay but if I go Knight E4 you go
Rook B8 I have long castles
so the funny thing for me is oftentimes
I have a night maneuver I want to get it
doesn't care it doesn't matter I want to
get to C7
oftentimes I don't have a choice I can
only go to B5 in order to get to C7 but
if I had my druthers if I had a choice I
almost always prefer to go through the
center because in my mind when I go to
the center yes I very much want to
capture a pawn but who knows maybe
there's a reason that my knight in the
center could go to the D6 Square light
you could blunder right you could put
and put a rook and it might be worth
what while for me to take the exchange
so for me this move is confusing so
there's absolutely you're saying there's
no benefit to Knight B3 but there might
be some extra benefits to 94. by going
through the center I I always think that
the knights in particular love to be
centralized so I'm I'm a Prejudice in
favor of 94. it didn't matter those it
didn't matter one way or another as it
turned out they the player still reached
the same position and arena is saying in
this ending my structure is a little bit
better than yours and is she right
Elmira is this a is this a position that
white can nibble
well the computer says that Uranus
position is a little bit better but as a
human player I think that this is not
enough to win the game here for example
I try to analyze this position let's say
Rook D1 Bishop D1 and I like those moves
like G5 here it's very important first
of all to fix those three pounds and the
difference is like after E5 I feel that
uh there is Bishop G4 and then now
you're going to face small troubles
gradually so this actually could be a
bit unpleasant but after G5 you know
White's Advantage is not clear to me at
all
okay that's simple by the way jump in
about that question about maneuvering a
knight in this case uh Arena was going
to capture the pawn on C5 would your
path have been the same Knight B3 Tech
C5 or would you have chosen Knight E4
um I think that Knight E4 is more
flexible because sometimes well the
threat of course is more important than
its execution so maybe you uh well you
would control the D6 Square let's say
you would play Knight 94 Knight to five
well you can take but you can make
another move you can wait you can Castle
along so
it's probably more flexible okay and but
again your choice would have been Knight
B3 or 94. 94. okay okay
work hard for a compliment around here
rough crowd rough crowd I'm here to
agree with you I mean it took an effort
Arena okay uh you're saying it's it's
even but I like the structure for white
I like Arenas you know you've got the
split pawns Kappa Blanca said it best
who has the most pollen Island stands
worse I think it's slightly better for
arena but I agree also with Almera that
the advantage isn't enough at this
moment
we'll see how that game uh unfurls
I'm so sorry no no just in uh to
complete your assessment of the position
because I really think that in order to
uh to claim the advantage in this
position you need Rooks at least one
Rook so you would be able to maneuver to
play Rook G3 Rook a 3 and to attack
those weaknesses but two minor pieces uh
well it's really not enough not enough
all right let's take a look at the other
game you're about to jump into Anna's
game because it looks like she hasn't
moved a piece all of her pieces are
still on the first round what's happened
so we have the nimso and after C5 that's
where I think we stopped and we're
looking at dtake C5 that was our primary
move we didn't really pay enough
attention to Anna's choice but the
result was this nice Tempo Knight C6 I
I'm familiar with these Tempo moves from
tarish where you know you get the
isolated Queen pawn and thanks to the
fact that the pawn is pinned you get to
develop with the tempo and oftentimes
this is a a Gambit actually Associated a
whole pond in this case it's just an
isolated Pawn but you're about to say
after the MU Queen A5 check it looks
like white has no development she chose
Knight D2 as opposed to the alternative
Bishop D2 noticing that B4 Knight takes
B4 could be in whoops maybe we don't
want to go there the Free Pawn yep
Knight D2 what did you were about to say
nothing yeah so it looks like black
doesn't have any problems out of the
opening we haven't isolated upon so in
the long term there might be a problem
but at the moment like so ahead in
development development black and Castle
right now right white still has to
develop the bishop probably to E2 right
and I think black has more than enough
time if they want to get rid of the
isolated Pawn to prepare D4 push even
yeah so you think black is doing
absolutely fine and even possibly Anna
has to be wary that she doesn't fall
into something
um well not so so happy let's just see
that was the arena game pardon me and
this was the Bellas game when she played
the move Bishop C5 she did offer a pawn
maybe it's not that important upon but
at the end of the day that's an extra
double Pawn this Pawn on E3 does do
stuff it covers squares Black's idea is
that hey
you know good good development good
centralizations worth a half upon the
only thing in White's position is the
night is stuck on G3 right defending
point on e4 right because if you give up
the E4 point just to improve your night
then
your advantage is gone completely right
then Black Knight will be great and
keeping the night on G3 I don't see how
white can be better with the nylon G3
the other thing that maybe is on Black's
agenda on a good day she may play for
example G6 and H5 threatening the
potential H4 provoking H4 and then
she'll end up having a nice Outpost for
her Knight once the moves H5 and H4 are
colluded that was why white uh since I
played a rook D3 first of all kind of
defending the pawn but more importantly
she wants to challenge for the control
of the D file please do me a favor take
my Rook so that it would three-hour
night yeah that would exactly that would
free the night defend upon on e4 so Rook
D3 uh preps the move Rook D1 your
feeling would you rather it's even it
should I think it's completely even like
for example if I play G6 and you get to
do your threat I'm not gonna accommodate
you by the way I'm not gonna just
happily uh much fix everything yeah yeah
yeah help your structure
um you just think that the extra Pawn's
not meaningful after all as long as
structure Remains the Same black should
be completely fine and Almira I want to
jump to you and uh get your insights
into this around three game well I
wanted to answer one of the most
difficult questions in chess should you
keep two Rooks in the position or one
Rook right so actually think that here
you have to take on D1 first ah yes in
this position after Bishop E6 I think
that black should have played Rook D1
more precisely yes precisely yes Rook D1
and after Rook D1 Play Bishop B3 so we
get exactly the same position only
with one Rook and I think that it will
be much easier for for black to defend
this one or at least to claim the
equality because you you no longer have
any threats with associated with Rook D6
or anything with the The Rook which are
doubled on the D file and I remember the
exercises I've been doing when I Was
preparing for the world championship
years years ago and Alexander chernin
explained to me that these were one of
the most important dilemmas in chess or
should you keep your queen on the board
should you keep two Rooks one rook and
what pieces do you have to trade and I I
really want to draw your attention
to this
uh well important aspect of Chester you
have to think about which pieces you
should trade or to keep on the board
and as you reference uh really a
fantastic coach Alexander chernin who by
the way played in My World Junior
Championships uh uh shout out to
Alexander what advice did he give you
well he was given me a lot of exercises
but there was no General no they're
absolutely no general rule and that's
what makes chess so complicated because
each position is unique and you have to
spend a lot of time and to understand
that I think that here uh well
now it's well computer agrees with me
curiously so let's have a look at the
position on the board
the current position the current
position yes of the board so this is
Rook D3 uh well computer give zeros I
feel that Bella might feel a little bit
uncomfortable because for example if you
take
on she did she did remarkably so she
already did let's say Rook G8 I don't
know yeah
and if you play C5 very simple move so
King F2 is C4
white still has D4 and while the
computer released this position is equal
I think that you might feel a little bit
uncomfortable here here I don't like
black at all because I think white king
comes to F3 protects E4 and then White's
Knight is free and it's a extra Pawn oh
so completely simple because okay C5 I
hear you no I get you King F2 C4 uh D4
and I understand what you're saying the
king will come to F3 but let's just
imagine go ahead put your King on it
and let's say I'm ready to give it
discovered I I always love those moments
where you go check
and I answer with check right so here
I'm re I'm begging you to play the move
d4 D5 check
so I could play Knight takes D5 check to
your cake sorry but also in this
position your thread is not H5 check
right correct I was going to do a
discount so I was thinking your king
might have to go away and then maybe
I'll go away and I'm waiting for you to
bring your king back so I'll go back and
forth if you play the move do you find
you your your structure loses a little
bit of Effectiveness I don't know
um it's not that clear to me uh it you
know it's a pawn it feels like an extra
Pawn but I real Cafe is a really nice
idea yeah it it it's not completely on
one goal uh again uh Judith's assessment
uh
Almira uh Drew this assessment it's
rather
eloquent four zeros four zeros four
zeros intriguing intriguing but I find
the move Rook takes D3 difficult to play
I feel that I'm helping my opponent a
lot there let's continue I have some
updates in Alexandra's game because oh
she played Queen G2 we need you to
instead of H4 which was much better
according to the engines Bishop takes
these one of the things about the
Marshall gambits right that I've admired
I never played it as wide and pardon me
as black I never played the Marshall
Gambit myself but I've always admired
the
um the dynamic play the initiative that
black receives for the pawn and it's
sort of like it's Charming because that
initiative actually carries oftentimes
into an ending I wouldn't call this an
ending I'd call this a late middle game
but the initiative is ongoing and we see
after Queen G2 we're expecting the move
Knight C2 and if
if white for some reason gets it in her
mind that she's better or you know she
could easily
end up losing the skin yeah but I could
say the same for black black also needs
to be careful and not get carried away
with the initiative right because they
aren't down
but we saw one position we were up a
full Rook but down six according to the
engines evaluation Queen G2 and uh take
it away Almira Queen G2
I'm a rook up
well easy for you to say yeah take it
away
let's have a look Bishop D3 so I was
right we needed to wait you know for
white to make a decision in a very
complicated position so can I chose to
play Queen G2 Knight C2 we already
analyzed this position before and we
know that we cannot play Rook B1 we
cannot save this Rook so I think in this
position you have two very safe options
you can take on C3 just give away this
Rook but you have one extra pound so you
have to
claim that you might be better somewhere
in the long run but after Bishop G2 the
computer says okay there is not much you
can you can play Queen E2
Bishop yes Bishop F3 and then he plays
Queen E6 he threatens to take the
opponent E2 and I think maybe there is a
quite a dynamic play but after Bishop D5
you know it says Queen A2 once again so
and Bishop F3 so that's where you
understand it the computer doesn't
understand anything because he repeats
the moves and the evaluation is still
better for why and here there is an
interesting move uh Bishop D5
so the idea is to take on F7 let's say
if you grab the The Rook on A1 then I
will take on F7 and King F7 Check Yes
Queen D5 check and let's say you protect
this bishop and you take the bishop on
D3 so your knight is no longer
threatened on F1 and here is hanging yes
Bishop is hanging he's going to take on
this is Perpetual Oh I thought white
could just give Queen E4 check and
perpetual yes you can but I don't know
why the computer yes takes on C3 because
I think that he keeps the option of
giving the Perpetual taking the bounce
so of course you can give Queenie for a
check but then you have to see all the
Perpetual so for me this line is quite
tricky I don't think that white will go
into this line because after Bishop B
takes C3 he thinks that it's still equal
because you can take this phone you can
take the pawn on E6 and your knight on
A1 is out of play but this is not human
at all no like if you're
well mildly insane I would consider
Bishop D5 and Bishop F7 but
so I think that b takes C3 is the move
the key move in this position
wow I'm still recovering from my mildly
and saying uh nice uh thank you uh for
that that is a crazy uh Marshall Gambit
position I must say and again I find
myself drawn to this ending between
Arena and Nana uh two players who tied
for second they both have one and a half
points and the more I'm looking at the
position I'm actually really liking
Arena's position I know what you're
saying Almera about G5 and you know the
fact that with the split pawns I'm
missing a rook like if I had a white
rook and I could put it on the C7 Square
I'm I'm happy if I had a white rook and
I could put it on the A5 Square I'm
happy I agree I'm missing a rook but I
also see you know weak pawns and I'm
thinking on a good day if I could
trundle my king
yeah I I could I could trade positions
with the Knight I could at least put a
lot of pressure on the C6 bond in the
meanwhile
I don't see black really using her
majority I mean yeah I I agree you're
you're going to be pushing the pawns and
I can imagine the pawns getting to E5
and F5 but I don't see a real chance for
a candidate passer over there
maybe on a good day I get to put my king
on C5 get to play B4 B5 good things
could happen so even though I'm not
thinking it's a win or anything like
that I'm just thinking I'd rather play
arena for sure I think white actually
has an objective advantage
yeah just one structure right the very
good night on C5 versus the really
passive bad Bishop on C8 for the moment
I but I I I do uh visualize that you
know if black can put the Knight on D4
put her Pawn on E5 the bishop the the
passive Bishop for now could emerge
um but yeah I I I'm liking Arena we'll
we'll keep an eye on this one sorry
Elizabeth's game with Anna
uh you you had mentioned uh now see that
if you were in black shoes you would
probably like to play D5 D4 would you be
doing it first by putting your Bishop
you know before you blow open the the
the the center your Rook should be uh oh
it developed there's no rush to play
before okay so we do have Bishop E2 on
the
boards they both look good right and you
you're kind of thinking you want to play
it with D4 at a certain point so go
ahead take us through your thought
processes here you would start with
Bishop F5 you would start with the Rook
I think I would play Rook d8 Rook david8
okay I'm castling
Quran
so now if I develop my Bishop you might
play Knight
be through with a Tempo and then id4
right yeah I was actually uh I was of a
different thought that I really really
really want to play B4
and I want to play Bishop B2 so I didn't
know if I wanted to use the tempo
against your queen or to try to set a
trap for you uh please fall for my trap
Knight takes B4 I can't recapture
because my Rook is hanging but I can use
the tempo
hit your queen defend the Rook take on
the next move so I was thinking I was
going to play B4 Bishop B2 but this is
right exactly and we could be getting
some kind of position that you you're
you're aspiring for where you get to
play D5 D4
um so here you do have Knight C4 I do
I might be losing that pawn after all
cool
it's my lucky day
Ah that's fantastic so sorry you're not
going to play D4 in that case you're
Almera has some updates for us please
Amira jump in well actually it seems
that you can play D4 in this position
immediately yes immediately and probably
equalize immediately because you
shouldn't be afraid of ghosts in this
position if uh White plays B4
you protect your knight by Queen D5 if
you play Bishop F3 Bishop F5 is a simple
defense once again so
but if after Queen D5 Knight E4 Queen F4
Bishop F3 a very important move Queen E6
you you're not allowing for white to
take on D4 with the power then if you
castle that's what I analyzed and Rook
did and I think that black is doing fine
here even in this bishop who's opposite
color even though you're a pawn down
you're doing just fine you think Bishop
Bishop C6 Queen C6 takes on D4 no
problems yes yes this is no you can take
like it takes the D4 yes well yeah this
bishop is actually uh well it's quite
passive here right yeah okay interesting
but you you started with uh black could
immediately equalize I think both Nasi
and I kind of had the feeling that
black could potentially be better
because white bounced or queen All
Around she went Queen C2 Queen C3 Queen
D4 Queen D1 so because she's so far
behind in development why isn't black
better
because that's that's really a paradox
because the uh the position is so solid
yes white has two Bishops a pair of
Bishops and its position is so solid
because you have no weaknesses
I think only white can your weaknesses I
just love the sound thank you very much
I have no weaknesses I think only white
can get away with such things in the
opening because if black was to waste so
many moves and not developed you would
be lost well exactly as a coach you sit
there and say don't become infatuated
with one piece we call Queen C2 Queen
takes E3 Queen to D4 Queen to D1 so a
lot of white moves with the queen but
the idea that white structure is intact
there's no weaknesses in the structure
even though she's behind in development
the two Bishops is a compensating factor
for the lack of development huh this is
how computer actually challenged the
classical doctrines now Orthodoxy yeah
yes so I think white has also a better
bound structure and I think if you have
this possibility you should use the
momentum and play D4 immediately wow
okay I just find that intriguing so one
once more we do have the position after
Bishop B2 by the way clock times between
Anna and Elizabeth Anna has 39 minutes
and Elizabeth 50. okay so let's just do
the most direct you know developing move
Bishop F5 Castles by white Rook on A8 to
d8 bring everybody into the party my
next move is Rook d8 do your worst what
do you think uh Anna should do in this
specific case
before all right perfect B4 let's go and
after B4 Queen B6 Bishop B2 perfect
let's go Rook d8 so I've got I mean I'm
as
I have to be proud of myself I am a
classical player look what I've done
I've put my Rooks in the center uh I've
have the isolated Queen Pawn uh but you
know I'm maybe maybe at long last I'm
ready to play D5 before go ahead so at
first I was gonna play Knight F3 but I
don't like that you have the option of
Bishop G4 okay I'm gonna go the other
way Knight B3 Knight to B3 okay fair
enough and we get a position well
Jennifer shahadi would say it's a time
for Rover Rook up and over you know I'm
supposed to
leverage my
my my uh Pawn structure control into
some kind if black had a black Square
Bishop somewhere on b8h to diagonal I
would be terrified of the rubber
exactly uh my knight on e4 as pretty as
it looks and it does look pretty is
somehow in the way of the bishop I would
prefer my Bishop on e4 so let me do
something a little bit unorthodox here
I'll drop back with my knight in order
to put my Bishop on
whoa the training is working my gosh
really can you do that
oh
[Music]
nasty okay so that's why we understand a
little bit that the two Bishops Bishop
on B2 even though I thought I did
everything right I brought my Rooks into
the center I completed my development
I'm prepared to play D5 D4 if
uh the the two Bishops yeah I think of
Blake Waits too long before pushing D4
they're just missed the opportunity to
play D4 and we uh our social media we
have a tweet
get ready everybody brace we have an
incoming
such as full time or do they have
another career first of all
the much for the question because I
think each and every one of these women
want to consider themselves
professionals but the difficulty in
women's chess is the opportunities they
don't have enough but some of them are
professionals right Amira I think that
almost all of them are professionals but
I think that you combine uh playing in
tournaments also with uh given lessons
some of them will also teach Arena crash
for example does a lot of uh chess camps
sorry please continue some of them are
doing commentary
could you be just here talking about
well Irina was the main commentator for
the ding Nepal world championship match
yes she was alongside with the swanathan
please continue uh yes and and I think
that well overall we we spend our time
dedicating Our Lives to chess I think
well I've been playing chess since I am
five I don't know nice how about two I
was five yeah
I was 12. if anybody's interested
I started late go on well I actually
it's not even about that because I think
that yes sir once again you're you've
been too dogmatic in your approach to
this position I'm proud of myself and
well Nancy has to be also more
subversive but here okay
I give you an opportunity to play D4
here you wanted to do it for such a long
time why not yes this is possible okay
and what is strange that computer gives
this move in this position so he goes
for this end game and he thinks that
white is slightly better but with the
weaker spawn structure yes with the
weaker pound structure but still the
pair of Bishops very powerful Bishops
but
as you
see I think that this is not enough once
again no yes to win the game yeah d5d
for a lot of it hinges on that sorry
Nancy I want you to jump in because you
are uh two-time U.S women's champion and
you won the title you won a good prize
but maybe it was one of the biggest
prizes that you've won in your career in
one tournament one tournament and it's
just that if you could play six U.S
women's championships per year and win
all of them or even to take second on
occasion
that would be enough for you to be a
professional and dedicate your life but
otherwise it's very hard to do that
right yeah like you said there are just
not enough strong tournaments with big
prize fun for women to play so a lot of
us do other
jobs as well yeah for uh
for me but also I want to say on behalf
of the chess club here in St Louis uh
chess club and Scholastic Center we're
very very proud of Carissa Yin there's
no question we're very very proud of
Carissa she's a a generational talent
and a top women's player but she made
the decision to go to Stanford get her
degree and everybody's proud of her and
that's fine but in some ways it's a
disappointing because from 18 to 22 is
such an informative period of time if
you're going to go and challenge you in
June and play for the Women's World
Championship and when I don't care a
million dollars
it's going to be hard for you to get the
Stanford degree so it's tough for us we
want women and we want to encourage more
women to play Chess at the same time we
have to give them more opportunities
right yeah absolutely and choosing
academic path it gives you some more of
a safety and guarantee so exactly
exactly even the great huyifan went to
Oxford and got her degree I believe
she's she's a professor in China One of
the University universities there but
yeah I'm still the highest rated female
player at the same time and still the
highest female Beta player yes
um more games what do you have for us
Amira well I was listening to a very
interesting conversations
mesmerized
yes
okay let's have a look at Irina okay we
didn't have by the way Elizabeth did
play immediately D4 as Almira suggested
immediately foreign
it's very important to trust your
abilities to calculate and uh well to
trust yourself so D4 uh is the move uh
which is very precise here so I think
that Elizabeth calculated this lines at
the very end okay it flashed through my
mind there in the game uh of Elizabeth
that after the move d4 is if you Castle
I wanted to play the move Knight takes
F2 and I had this I I got Charmed by
this idea of dragging your king up the
board and maybe
asking some very saline questions here
you know you've seen these Bishop
sacrifices on H2 uh is that it with the
Rook that's the kick my king safe please
safely tucked in the corner right
uh so I will be only down one paw
only one only one well but hey let me
Pat myself on the back there as I uh in
France in France we would say the petite
combination
what a change of Paradigm you know two
minutes ago you were claiming an
advantage
[Music]
now your phone down and you know you're
happy if you will make a draw
well but I think it's a brilliant
combination native too oh well yes king
of two I'm a sucker for flattery go on
it's not the move that you're going to
make in this situation and well
certainly you're not going to take only
three so
but here you also have Queen B6 check
and maybe you can even grab the pound on
bitsu well it's better than one Pawn
being one Pawn up
two yes yes so uh you have to watch out
in this position when it has to be very
careful yes after D4 and actually uh
Anna has only 35 minutes left this is
one already on the Move what move is it
move uh move 13 yes it's a critical
moment of the game
mm-hmm wow okay so D4 that's why we are
capturing on D4 is that uh is that I
think or we were playing I think we're
capturing I think we're looking at B4
yes yes sorry it was the B4 Queen was
coming across and this was don't be
worried about ghost variation that
um uh Amira was mentioning uh I've also
heard arena is a little bit for Choice
uh I suppose that the combination of the
moves Nana didn't play G5 no she played
E5 instead correct well I think she
actually played King E7 first king D2
okay but she is inviting Bishop G4
maybe there's a little bit awkwardness
going on maybe she just wants to play 96
and exchange the Bishops okay now this
is interesting because uh
um
I have some very uh strong uh ideas
about night endings okay so my ideas
about nine endings is they're very very
similar to King and pawn Index right
right you really should know your
kingdom on end games inside out the
second thing about the night endings is
funnily enough
blank ponds become more important in
night endings than Central Pawns right
which is kind of contrary to whatever
we've been told we've always been taught
capture towards the center right control
the center control the center in night
endings an a pawn
pardon me an a pawn as well as a H Pawn
those are the terrible passers for the
knights so you're saying that would be
much stronger than the E5 precisely
because if I have a white knight you
have a a passer in the center and I have
a blockading night my night is on e4
blockading your Pawn my knight is
actually doing things uh blockading in
the center if you have a blockading
night on A7 I have a passer on A6 your
knight is off the board it's not it's
not paint playing a role so in a in a
pure night ending what I'm saying is
White's Queen side majority is actually
more powerful than the king side how
that gets
um
matched to the position at hand don't
know but those General world right it
might still not be enough to win
necessarily right but white definitely
has that small Advantage I'm a bit
surprised by the move King C3 by the way
she did not play uh Bishop G4 King C3
okay she did it uh so now I assume
Black's gonna play Knight D4 that's I
think the whole point of uh Nana's play
to now is remember you told me that the
bishop on C8 was passive right so
putting the pawn on E5 opening up the
diagonal makes perfect sense so Arena of
course sees that this is happening as
she does she want a bishop ending does
she want to play the move Knight B3
don't think so think so phone block
doesn't have to exchange after the MP3
but
um of course white should we plan on the
queen side that's where we have the
advantage three versus two right should
white include move F4 here and create an
isolated Pawn on E5
does it help white or not well first of
all
yeah am I am I isolating the pawn like
like I'm just thinking like uh
I'm I'm not necessarily isolating the
pawn right if it if it was just like I
could play F4 and magically trade off
the F Pawn I'd be considering it the
problem that I have with F4
is I always look at it and I say am I
playing on your agenda or am I playing
on my agenda when I look at this
position and I see you have in a
majority on this on the center and the
King side I'm thinking that's your
territory you know my sphere of
influence is the queen side what you
were saying so I'd be a little bit
reluctant to play F4 unless I was
isolating as you said that
um jump in on this uh oh I see you got
the Alexandria game you're you're
looking there
um my feelings here are that uh black as
as done well that uh yes that the the
especially if you could get a G5 right
away I beginning to think that uh black
has no problems whatsoever so I'm
thinking King C3 is a little bit
inaccurate tell us about the uh our
tournament leader Alexandra Costa New
York is she doing uh Amira yes sir I was
completely stunned by the position on
the board no this is my analysis so
Alexander actually played C2 here an
amazing move she's still a rook down but
all of the whites are pieces are
completely paralyzed and so
after the move A3 black has this
incredible move Knight A2 yes
exactly what else can you do on the
other hand you know I think that this is
the only move which holds the position
together so you'll have to take on A2
Queen Sivan B4
and after Queen B1 white has to give the
Rook back Rook C2
Queen C2 and a very important move Queen
C6 so I want to trade Queens
breathe for a little bit
phew of course a black shouldn't trade
Queens here and after Queen Z1 queen
queen eight Bishop f8 Bishop G2 I was
trying to understand
well if black can create many more
threats but I think that this position
is equal now so the two Bishops and
black species activity compensates for
the bomb right but I think this this is
the variation that we're going to see on
the board
a lot of fireworks but it does look like
it's petering out there as uh Alexander
costing you got tournament leader
sacrificed a rook to get up to to get
these martial Gambit compensations and I
agree with you the two Bishops feels
like a draw right but all of all of
Alexandra's games this tournament all
three of them have been fireworks
I know she's definitely brought us we
get ready for break we want to say that
here in Missouri they're celebrating
their Bicentennial 200 year anniversary
and it Dr Jeannie singfield got a chance
to be a part of those festivities with
an Eagle Scout project marble
marble board chessboard have a look
[Music]
in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parsons approved the building of a
life-size chess board to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a patron
of scouting in Great Rivers Council
board member proposed that the project
be built as an Eagle Scout project
Jeannie invited 16-year-old Andrew
doughton of troop 6 Jefferson City to
take on this incredibly important
project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chessboard
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite I
wasn't very familiar with the technology
needed to engrave on there so I needed
some assistance with that and learning
how to do it and after all that I'm
pretty sure I know how to do it now so
to engrave those Edge pieces I went down
to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we use the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
it ended out to be a really really cool
project so we had a ribbon cutting of
the chess board and there were a whole
bunch of people there including the
governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project Jeannie was
there I had to give a little speech that
I didn't really know I had to do but
that kind of has taught me a little bit
about speaking too so I think that has
helped me too this project it's made me
real proud that everyone is enjoying it
like every time I go down there
somebody's playing
and then they're taking care of it which
really makes me proud because me sinking
all that time and everyone else that's
helped me sinking in all that time I
like to see people use it but I also
like to see people appreciate it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our results in round three so far we
have one drop in the all Indian Derby
nothing really happened they just tested
each other's opening hours yes and they
both knew what they were doing well
today uh we seem to be having a number
of bras we've been catered by an 80
decisive uh rape let's just jump into
the games as we saw this very important
move in the game of our tournament
leader Alexandra she sacrificed a whole
rook in a marshall Gambit so first she
sacrifices upon for the initiative that
she sacrificed a rook she won Back The
Rook uh but she still is the pawn down
but here White's Queen is remarkably
passive you don't want to follow in a
position where you're stuck on the
defending the Knight with your queen
this is an important move Queen C6 even
though I'm not going to trade Queens I'd
probably by either Queen D1 and or queen
B1 the whole idea is you could go check
Force the bishop back and rather than
having your queen stuck on G2 Bishop
goes to G2 White's a pawn up but she's
not going to be able to do anything with
her extra Pawn this game seems to be
headed for a draw let's go to the game
also uh interesting one where we're upon
up but we're having trouble doing
anything yeah it is a theme we're having
a very hard time with white gaining an
advantage when we right here
um
an indication she doesn't have an active
plan after B5 played the move Rook D2 on
our break we were mainly focused on H5
we're looking at H5 and A5 for black and
we're considering an event is black
slightly better maybe because it's sort
of like White's pieces are a little bit
stuck this Knight in particular has
nothing to play for on the other hand If
It Moves Knight takes e4s not what you
exactly had in mind and in the meanwhile
maybe we'll get a passer so this
position despite being a pawn down feels
like black is doing fine Rook C8 an
indication that we're still thinking
about A5 B4 and C3 as well then let's
come to the game of Arena crash and Nana
I thought that it was incumbent upon
Arena to actually improve the positioner
for King that is to say to dry to get
the king to C5 may be on a good day
escort her pawns home she's pushed her
pawns forward with the moves B5 and A4
and I have to say that for me
that that doesn't help her cause and the
positions more balanced than ever before
G4 response surprised me to G5
wow yeah but it does you're right yeah
it's a little bit strange I mean it kind
of fixes Black's King side Parts yeah
but at the same time we're putting the
pawn on the white square where a black
Bishop can attack it and our Bishop has
to defend it right but I like you said I
don't think it changes the evaluation it
still should be exactly and uh finally
that that leads us to uh the remaining
game that's the game between uh Anna and
Elizabeth we did see that move D5 D4 and
took on D4 which is a little bit
surprising but we I think the crazy part
in this game is that they're on move
14. Yeah Anna has 12 minutes left 12
minutes and her first four moves were
instant like D4 C4 Knight C3 first four
months right yeah so say it again so 12
minutes left for 26 moves 26 moves yes
yeah they just it's a tough position
it's it's not an easy position where you
can just you know develop Castle
exchange pieces no she has to be careful
wow uh we know that she likes thinking
and but that oftentimes she does it to a
great deal of excess well Knight takes
D4 what can I say I mean I'm looking at
the position of course I'm going to
Castle right I don't think I have
another I mean well B4 B4 with the idea
of capturing I think it's just going to
provoke Queen D5 and 0.5 or queen F5 why
am I helping my opponent centralize
their pieces so let's see castles
I wouldn't exchange the my knight on e4
for your night on D2 so I'm just going
to go back Knight F6 you're gonna go
back you're not even going to take my
Bishop
say I like my night on D4 so much that's
fine okay so away you go I want to play
Bishop F5 next and use my knight on D4
to put pressure on the queen side yes I
get it but I do have a plan myself now
Knight B3 I would find it attractive but
in this case let me let me put my knight
on C4 where again I like my knight
centralized so Knight to C4
tickling the queen attacking the Knight
Quincy five
oh you're playing with fire I always
have an id2 in between uh you might not
always be on tap I take that back Queen
D5 looks better Queen David five okay
Queen to D5 uh Bishop to E3 not much
else I gotta develop developing is
important 92 and finally we get our
Bishops of opposite color position is it
a date for draws it feels like a lot of
a lot of very equal positions uh I I
don't think either player has a
significant advantage in our little uh
conversation we were having I'm seeing a
lot of even positions how about you
Elmira
well actually I think that given the
time Factor Elizabeth should have tried
something else this is the position that
I was analyzing but here she had another
move and she could pose a lot of
problems to Anna she could have played
Rook d8 so keeping the pressure for the
moments on the board so let's say what
if your Castle here
yes you want to finish your development
but here look at the evaluation of the
position it's already minus one after
Rook D4 so you and as it was absolutely
right you have to be careful but only
after Rook d8 so after Rook d8 you have
to probably you have to play the move
before okay yes because you have to get
rid of this pin so let's say queen F5
94 Queen A4 and then you can Castle
94 but this is a different position and
Anna has very little time so I think
that Elizabeth should have tried this I
also analyzed another line here
before queen of Queen D5 so uh well if
you try to defend the pawn bishop B2
simply Knight D2
Queen Z2 and queen G2 so yes this is a
very nice position for black after Queen
D5 what did they what else did they try
no that was that was it yes I think that
question now Mira when you when whenever
I see these types of position I always
look at Knight takes B4 like in that you
play B4 I play Knight B4 well yeah
absolutely right but the computer gives
a very strange variation so let's try it
as usual you know 94. okay and then
Knight C2 all right double check Double
Check Yes certainly so King F1 you know
neither Rock yes neither one
right and this uh the fact that he is
hesitating here you know proves that you
know that this position is not so simple
to evaluate and I'm not sure that black
wants to enter this position especially
after D4 because it's very complicated
of course you can play Queen D5 Knight
C3 but white still has two minor pieces
[Music]
yes you can yes you can take on the one
Bishop E6 black has sufficient
compensation but it's not easy to
evaluate if you should enter this
variation at this point of the game
especially when you play D4 you want to
equalize and to have a comfortable
position right and it's not really the
position per se it's also the clock
right the clock Factor uh do you want a
complicated position when you have
little time no no you don't and 12
minutes the honor we all know and love
uh they're from many many U.S
championships way way down on time but
maybe that was a Mis missed opportunity
for Elizabeth Rook d8 was far more
chaotic and complex than Knight takes D4
it might just be that we're just going
to see a lot of hacking and uh Bishops
of opposite color should we say that
real Anna is back the real Anna is that
yes well the real Anna
AS stand up uh yeah and again just uh so
many decisive games eighty percent for
rounds one and two I'm afraid we're not
going to say that today I don't think so
not from the positions that we had I
just want to go to the Alexandria game
for a moment because again this is like
it's confounding it and happening in the
same round that two players are up upon
right it may stand worse how weird is
that
referring to the game of Alexander she's
black she's a pawn down after the move
Queen to C6
Alexandra properly kept the Queens on
the board because it's for for me the
queen trade should only occur uh if our
King is vulnerable if our king is not
vulnerable we're not trying to trade
Queens in this case White's King is
vulnerable so she's trying to trade
queens and just that combination of the
white square bishop and the queen is is
the compensation for the pawn absolutely
as well as the fact that this bishop
which is the second Bishop in the
position is matched paired with the
Knight on F1 the bishop actually on f8
does more good in the position than the
Knight on F1 after Bishop G2 Bishop back
to uh B5
I find it easier to play Black because
I'm thinking okay I'm gonna go Queen A1
your queen is probably going to stay
on the third rank so it's going to be
Tethered to the a pawn your Bishop is
going to be Tethered to the Knight is
going to improve with black well I'm not
I'm just saying I have I find it easier
I'm going to keep the position and okay
I don't say that I will ever win the
pawn you know with an A5 break but I'm
just saying that I love it I absolutely
love keeping my opponent tied up I mean
so that they're they're incapable of
moving yeah that's that for me is a kind
of a an ideal I'll Merit jump in it's
the does the engine say White's better
no they no of course not and uh shows
the perfect equality but it dawned upon
me and finally 30 moves later yeah I
understood what Alexander preparation is
about the depths of her preparation once
again so that's the position that we
have on the board so after Queen the
three you're absolutely right I think
that you have to put the queen on A1
right but then uh of course it's not so
easy for white to entangle the pieces
and I understood that probably Black's
ID is to play G6 Bishop G7 Bishop B2 and
at some point black might even be better
so let's try because I haven't tried
this variation yet with the computer so
after Queen A1 let's try the move H4 can
we try G6 here I know maybe we shouldn't
allow it H5 yes the computer plays H5
first okay so you should make a move
with your queen probably Queen F3 G6
okay
my plan should come to
execution and see the computer already
gives a slight slight Advantage okay he
changes his mind but after Bishop G7
you're absolutely right it might be
easier for black to play and I have a
few threads indeed so let's only piece
that white can move is the queen
I mean uh obviously you would love to
break the uh pin on the first rank but
if you try to play moves like F3 and
King F2 in order to break the pin you'll
probably be doing
The Cure is worse than the disease
you're probably making more weaknesses
than you would like with F3 in King F2
so our tournament leader I'm saying is
not in any danger of losing and yeah if
anything if kunai makes sliding
actresses Alexandra will have a chance
to fight for more exactly something
could slip there and let me just go
around the horn a little bit more this
is the game
versus Bella did have H5 H4 I think this
inclusion is very useful very useful for
black why because this Knight not only
is it tickling E3 it does suggest that
there is a possibility of Rook uh over
to f8 and F2 and
you know
it you you have this very
angry feeling that you know you you're
fighting and you're upon up and
you're not enjoying it
the extra part what's wrong with the
world you keep asking yourself why am I
worse why am I the one uh on the back
foot why am I defending it so black has
two ideas Rook f8 is one of them and
also a5b4 and opening up a file and
maybe going Rook A8 and from other side
that would be a very nice one and what
about what about if I've just uh crudely
uh try to you know play C3 and Rook take
C3 and you know keep that position fixed
as well so do you think black has
chances to play for more drop
no but I think it's just like a much
more comfortable and easy draw for black
than you would think being a pawn down
Arena Arena Crush again uh these two
ladies are having a successful
tournament uh both are tied for second
one and a half points out of two behind
our tournament leader and uh well if
Alexandra does draw the winner of this
game could join her join her but we've
been thinking for some time that
actually Nana's doing just fine and the
last few moves kind of indication of
that F5
H3 King D6 and I think both players are
a little bit stuck at this moment hard
to improve
with either side right because you don't
want to over push no that's the one
thing about the pawns they don't move
backwards yeah
Victor would Victor coach now when uh
when I was working together they had
this wonderful uh I I wanted that we
have what we call the Texas draw Texas
yeah drawl oh okay oh well holy their
partner you know and and Victor had
Victor cortionally had this Russian
drawl that kind of went yes sir
pawns don't move backwards
I'd be playing G4 G5 you know exposing
my king you know yeah and exactly the
pawns don't move backwards in this
particular case
um black has achieved more or less the
maximum she doesn't want to go any
further uh moves like F4 would only have
not allow a be helpful for white and
give up the E4 Square so this game looks
like it's heading for a draw Amira
jumping to you uh of our four games what
games caught your eye first of all I
wanted to draw your attention to this
position uh computers seem he doesn't
like the move H3 if you want to play for
a small advice Advantage here why it
should have taken on F5 and I actually
wanted to have your opinion what would
the Natalie karpov say here after Bishop
F5 Knight B3 should we exchange raw
Knights those nights or should you play
96 here
okay and should we be trading the
knights oh that's a question for you yes
excuse me
well I mean
um
no I I I I wouldn't I I would if I was
black I would like to keep the night
actually I would play night back to E6
to F4 I think that Knights E6 is a very
important move you you shouldn't trade
the knights because I think that the
Natoli karpov would be quite happy with
this end game you know it might give him
some chances and he could try and win
this okay so uh but after age three yes
which was played in the game H3 and then
King D6 here you know he evaluates this
position is equal and you're absolutely
right yeah and uh thank you Amir we do
have a tweet uh brace yourself incoming
let's see what we have this one is from
I'm threes on Instagram on Instagram the
question is tips for amateur chess
players let me take this one first
because this one is so easy for me if
you're in the St Louis area here come
and visit the St Louis chess club as
well as the World Chess Hall of Fame and
imbibe the chess goodness that goes on
here in the Central West End in St Louis
the club is really really magnificent we
have a lot of coaches uh chess lessons
chess lectures by top Grandmasters there
you see there are classes for children
they're just for adults they're ladies
nights every Thursday nights indeed and
the World Chess Hall of Fame right
across the street some great exhibit
exhibitions going on the TS Eliot
exhibition is going on as I speak and I
got to tell you that it really is a
worthwhile visit other than that also
seriously check it out tips for amateurs
go on the YouTube it's unbelievable how
many lectures I was just going to say
that if you're not in San Luis area
there's they offer online lessons as
well right and there's so much already
free in information that's incredible
Saint Louis YouTube chess Channel and
many others yeah you could even pick up
some lectures from urugu nakovian it's a
name but one of the many uh lectures
that are available and I believe of
course that the St Louis has a channel
as Sabina for example uh dorsa is was
recently uh on the channel and that is a
kind of a constant if you will we always
tournaments are going on not just the
Karen's Cup and the U.S championships
but the classics as well and we do have
a special guest in a studio uh who is
with Almera over to you Emma
yes hello and we have very special guest
today hello Mike so I'm here with Mike
Isaacson so you're an artistic director
and an executive producer of the minions
can you tell me a little bit about the
music and how important a landmark it is
in St Louis well
that's a great question
like the St Louis chess club and the St
Louis Chess Hall of Fame World Chess
Hall of Fame
um it is a singular International
National Institution right here in St
Louis
we're in our 105th season and it is the
world's largest outdoor theater there
are 11 000 seats
uh we produce seven
huge Broadway musicals this summer we
perform for thousands of people each
night and each night we also have
um
1500 free seats so anybody from the
community can come it's a huge tradition
here in life in St Louis it's usually
about a life of going to musicals at the
muni in our beautiful Forest Park during
the summer which is
three blocks from you know here we are
at the at the chess club and it's just
this incredible beautiful tradition and
people just love it and we have this
connection to the worldwide musical
theater Community Broadway London people
come from all over the world to perform
on our stage and we have like the top
talent Tony Award winners Olivier Road
winners incredible designs and it's a
huge part of life in in St Louis and um
something we're really proud of
whoa
you're an award-winning producer and
director
I know a lot about you please reveal us
the secrets about the new coming the
upcoming season and especially about the
chess Musical
so uh as you said I'm the artistic
director and executive producer and sort
of my real uh job
besides being responsible for everything
that's on the stage when you see the
show that night at the muni is just sort
of really understand the audience and
what excites them and their imagination
and chess has been a dream of mine since
this is my 12th season since I walked in
the door because it is this like it's
like the greatest musical you've never
heard it is a wonderful wonderful
Musical that was an international hit
and this is our first time at the muni
uh it's a real premiere for us first
time we've done the show which I am so
excited about the music it first began
as a album an incredibly popular album
around the world uh in the late 80s
and it sold internationally there was a
song One Night in Bangkok that became a
dance hit somewhere there was a duet I
know him so well all these songs the
music's by the guys who did all the
album music and the lyrics are by Tim
Rice who did Jesus Christ Superstar and
Evita and all these great musicals and
so it's this incredibly Rich Bold Rock
and rolled score in music and told in
this incredibly vibrant Styles and um
people just love it and a weird thing
happened with it historically they first
did it in London and it was a huge hit
ran for four years and just it was a
massive hit then they brought it for
Broadway for reasons I don't know why
they decided to change the script change
a lot and it didn't work it closed very
quickly on Broadway but it was sort of
still this legendary show and it went
out on a national tour in a different
form but it continued to be popular
worldwide world of mouth PBS did a big
concert version with Josh Groban Idina
Menzel it's been done it's been done in
Russia it's been done in the Far East
all over the place so finally because of
the St Louis chess club and the World
Chess Hall of Fame we have this amazing
partnership and we can bring it to the
muni and we're going to use the original
London script we're going to use what
was a huge hit which basically
celebrates the Glorious music of the
show and it's really really exciting and
on everyone in St Louis is so excited
about it and we've already anticipated
my question but what is your personal
vision of the musical
well
you know there's nothing greater that
when you go to the theater or and you're
surprised you walk in and you think I
don't know what this is and it takes you
on a journey and you love the music and
you find the characters and you just you
know you get an experience that
transports and you know time is on our
side because as if you're watching this
you know chess has never been more
popular in the United States it's
incredible thanks to the great work of
everyone here so we're Landing it right
A Moment Like even people who don't know
chess are curious about it and why is
everybody talking about it so this the
story within the show tells the story of
an international chess tournament
Russians versus the US and the the two
men playing and of course the second
four uh one is a woman who maybe falls
in love with another so you sort of get
this sense of intrigue and personal
stake but you know everything that's
been explored in popular culture right
now with the Queen's gamut and all the
things you know people are really
interested in like why why does someone
play the game why is this game so
popular through history there's a song
in the show The Story of Chess that
gives you how chess came about
um so it's hitting it right the moment
people are really curious and excited
well I had a question for you know I was
born in the Soviet Union Yes and well
I've lived through these chess stories
but on the other side and I wanted to
ask a personal question for example how
did it touch you personally when Bobby
Fischer played the match against Boris
fosky
well I was young then or younger let's
say that what I remember what a great
question what I remember so specifically
is
this was going on and clearly it was
important
and it was it was a game being played
like you know I knew Sports and
Athletics the other day of game but this
I knew was different like the the stakes
of it and the idea of what it meant to
the world I'd never seen anything like
that before like that was new to me at
the time like oh a game matters
worldwide I mean you sort of have it
with the Olympics I guess but that's its
own a different kind of energy this was
I remember it was just in in the papers
remember newspapers it was in the papers
every day and it was on TV and
everything about it was so and it was
sort of the thing where you went oh I
need to investigate this
and I'll admit I I did play chess I was
terrible I played it a lot in high
school I was not successful at it so I'm
aware of the game but I don't play it
because I'm not good
well thank you so much for this
wonderful interview and I'm actually
looking forward to the chess musical
because I've seen it several times I
love the music isn't the music great
it's fantastic music yeah yeah okay so
and please come everyone Everyone's
Watching come to St Louis come teach us
thank you very much Mike thank you very
very good luck with the with the shows I
feel so lucky I'm going to be in San
Luis live July 5th to 11th so you know
we're going maybe every day right right
no no no no no no for sure and I got the
story of the musical chess
I got the story oh yeah so in 1981 I was
in Murano Italy for the World Chess
Championship match between Victor course
Noy and Anatoly karpov and Victor was
playing terribly and I kicked him out of
the hotel we were staying at the palace
hotel in Murano go do your lung Lao
forget about Chess just get it out of
your mind and I spent a delightful
evening with the gentleman
oh
was really over the top ridiculous so
what his story was is he was going to
make a musical on chess
and I said well that's a ridiculous idea
he said no yes sir it's not I said it's
not chess where you go in and the first
thing they do is say silence don't talk
you're gonna make a musical on Jazz
that's the worst idea I've ever heard in
my life and then he began to describe to
me as vision
I was like wow that's actually
interesting and he says no Yasser is
going to be great it's going to do
so at the end of the evening I said well
you have me at a disadvantage my name's
Yasser and he said my name is Tim Rice
it's nice to meet you Tim I walked at
the door saying our good night say wait
a minute
Jesus Christ Superstar Tim Rice Andrew
Lloyd Webber I turned back and I said
you're Tim Rice you're going to do a
musical on chest he says that's what
I've been talking about for five hours
already so I knew a musical on chess was
coming am I set my alarm I woke up to
One Night in Bangkok and I said oh my
God that was the song that Tim sang to
me wow yeah it was like amazing amazing
jumping into the game uh let's see Anna
versus Elizabeth we did get into this
Bishops of opposite color position but I
was really surprised by the move Knight
B3 by Anna I thought we were looking at
Knight C4 I thought that made a lot of
sense to attack the queen and again I
like the knights to be a little bit more
centralized Knight B3 was her choice and
the difference was that after Queen D5
if the Knight was on C4 we would
immediately of course be very happy to
play the move Rook D1 as the knights on
B3 Anna felt that she had to play Queen
D1
Queen C4
just kind of catching up to the players
here a little bit Bishop to G5 okay I'm
threatening to move Rook C1
um what's going on
I asked first
you were really fast yeah uh can black
boy Bishop G4 yes because B3 is making
me a little uncomfortable it's not that
well protected for sure right exactly
that is for sure
um
oh why it has Queen D4 nice that's what
I wanted yeah I wanted to say that the
bishop uh being defended by the Knight
and the Knight being under attack I
think I have to move Queen D4 Just In
Time by the way just otherwise maybe I'm
a little bit uh uncomfortable having to
play a move like F3 uh here uh but okay
uh Bishop to G5 could you tell me the
clock times because I know Anna is
really down eyes down to five minutes
and 40 seconds oh dear for for 21 moves
five minutes for you know she's supposed
to start with 90 minutes for 40 moves
how did she get five minutes for 20 okay
and uh 25 minutes for Elizabeth okay so
the clock is a is a big big factor
Bishop G5 and I think in the next like
two or three moves it's really going to
define whether anybody's better because
if we go for the variation we were just
looking at Bishop G5 Queen D4 I think
that
kills the game essentially and I'm sure
Elizabeth is looking for ways to
complicate the position exactly just to
put pressure on Anna's clock exactly but
it's not easy to find a way to
complicate this right so for a move like
I would find myself attracted to
whenever you're telling me keep it
complicated well what are you actually
saying keep pieces on the board is what
you're saying so 94 trying to keep
pieces on the board I'm assuming Rook C1
do I have an id2
well
I asked and answered that's a very good
move 92 if you're tracking trade thesis
that that does it and this is this is
what I mean if you can't complicate the
position uh it's going to be dead very
very very shortly Arena versus
whoa this is when I push the pawn all
the way to A5 okay I was wondering if if
black was going to get a chance to play
85 she didn't A5 King C7 Knight B3 and
we've caught up with the players why did
we go King C7 I'm not sure but okay this
is the suit but now black has to
exchange the knights earlier when almir
asked you if you would exchange he said
96. yeah I would have preferred the
night to go to E6 in this case you don't
have that option 96 takes could we just
export another move or two because there
is the move F6
but let's say I take pains to make sure
that the pawn doesn't go too far
on a good day
hello Bishop G4
okay Bishop to G4 what is uh remember
what I was telling you about the night
endings and how I respect the the corner
points well yeah the outside pawns
versus the central pawns more here we're
seeing a manifestation of that right
after the move uh B5 okay so uh it means
I have to trade nights yes
or maybe you could start with f text G4
here
ah
I think that's a possibility as well I
like it
uh
I'm I'm still not too sure tell me what
you what do you think about the king
yeah what do you think about this uh
Bishop ending is it
do you feel like it's anything here okay
I I'm not sure let's say I play King D6
and just wait I think it's just equal I
don't see how I can improve right I'm
just keeping the all the tension in the
position and
I don't know I I'm pretty sure you don't
want to play C5 but if you play B5 in a
premature moment my king might actually
just be very very very well placed on C5
but you know elbowing you blocking you
blocking your king from getting into the
position
um this is an important game Almira for
our tournament results as two players
who are tied for second are going Head
to Head how is the position from the
engine's perspective well both of you
are
and I think
they need to understand and this
position was the move H3 that what
changes the evaluation because this
weakness is very important so now you
can actually take on B3 King B3 and you
might even play F4 but King D6 is a very
good as well so because white cannot
progress right cannot change a draw
seems
I like a likely outcome
in the game I wanted to go to Bella
where are you Bella poor one he's in
cyber yeah this was the thing uh ever
since she won the half Pond the extra
Pawn for white uh Society has been in a
situation where strangely enough her her
pawns and pieces are stuck in mud uh the
night on G3 has to remain on G3 uh
keeping the pawn on e4
White's not really that interested in
playing D5 because then her her position
her structure loses all flexibility in
the meanwhile black is
expanding on the queen side and we feel
that Bella's Maybe
slightly better with the black there's a
Time Factor also he only has four
minutes left
while John said has 35 minutes
and they still have eight moves to make
so I guess Bella's trying to reach the
time control and then see if she can
actually play for a win here exactly
what was her last moves by the way we
can see that from White's point of view
white is actually her last four moves
have been with her Rook she's just been
moving to and fro if you will with the
Rook so that's an indication right there
that white is not playing uh for to
making progress
and I think in the game if you quickly
jump to Anna's game okay things have
simplified completely we have opposite
color Bishops yes and the Rooks left on
the board so Elizabeth as much as she
would like to try to exploit the uh time
trouble of her opponent no she couldn't
keep the pieces on the board and this
looks like it's definitely going to a
draw probably going out look for uh
three more repetitions and they're very
very good they will discover a three
move repetition uh no doubts so I mean
again we we came in
uh so much fireworks so many decisive
games in the first uh two rounds of play
eighty percent of our games are decisive
really things have settled down uh
greatly I just want to go to our
tournament leader for just a moment
because we just seen this last move g i
what Almira was saying that you go go go
play G6 go play H5 then see what you can
do about Bishop G7 and maybe uh Bishop
B2 try to take this Pawn keep
the pressure on the first frame this
move Queen C7 sets a little trap it says
a petite take my Pawn please take my
pawn queen takes Bishop uh is going to
jump to D5 right and now you have to
defend well that's mating too right you
have to defend with Bishop to E8 and I
was thinking that there was a force way
here it flashed in my mind there was a
force way of making a draw
now I can't remember what I was thinking
attach them Bishop maybe yeah was it
Queen
I can't defend with Queen A4 right
um seriously I I thought I I I saw a
forced no I don't I don't think Queen B8
is good okay um
maybe we can free our night or is that
too slow well I like you know hitting
the bishop at least let's one more time
let's hit yeah and let's see how where
how can we bring our Knight what's our
most effective Square
E5 E5 would be great E5 is great the
green moves to get there okay let's do
it that's one
and this is two
and so we're going to go E5 or G5 next
and it's kind of funny we're turning the
tables a little bit
at one moment you had me on the back
rank pin
now the tables have turned yeah uh now
I've got you on the back rank pin It's
Kind of a Funny situation I have the
tables turned what's going on Amira well
I wanted you to discover it yourself
before you played Queen D7 this position
this is minus point oh yeah you did
everything as usual to lose this well
we're doing our best yes you're doing
your best here you have Quincy one so I
think so
and then you keep an extra pound right
and of course this bishop is is a very
important defense sir
he keeps the fort
so after Bishop f8 this position is
completely winning right but actually I
don't like the trend you know because
maybe you could have tried Bishop C4
here uh not Queen
C7 but Bishop C4 and it's important well
to exchange the B4 pound against the A6
Pawn but I think that the trend is not
going in your way because look at this
diagonal so maybe I can put my Bishop on
C6 I don't know I can try something so
it's uh well you definitely have will
have to suffer for a draw right uh
but Alexandra didn't take on A3
she did not yes she played Queen D1
after h3g6
the position is still equal right but I
wonder if well she's preparing uh
Bishop's G7 maybe bishop G4
also a very important conclusion then
you can put King G7 so you have to you
will have to play H5 at some point
anyway so let's say
why just played H3 but let's say H4 H5
then you make a queen move so and now I
can play maybe bishop G7
so Queen said back
King age seven and it's more pleasant
for white to play this is surprisingly
more present for black for black sorry
yes to be able to play this absolutely
it's uh
again uh for me as a chess Grandmaster I
hate being pinned down and this
background bin is really annoying the
results uh this far this far we only
have one result draw between Toronto
Valley and coneru and other four games
are still going on but it looks like we
have equal positions everywhere yes
across the board Anna zatonski and uh
Elizabeth Hayes definitely uh boy
there's
talk about equality I was about to say
the structure if black would put his her
Pawn on A6 it would almost be an
identical Pawn structure as time is no
longer a factor a draw definitely is the
outcome of this one Arena Crush okay B5
that's I don't know did I
I was about to say that once Arena has
established a pawns on A5 and B5 Black's
King is going nowhere you you're
definitely going to stay in the vicinity
of the queen side on the other hand
um White's King doesn't have
any possibilities of breaking yet but F5
Pawn's going to get either exchanged on
G4 or on F5 right or black might push F4
but that also looks
a little bit maybe it's fine too but
either way it looks like white will have
access to E4 square but does that change
anything
I I I'd be uh very doubtful because I
just I'm having a very hard time
imagining where White's King is breaking
through I could put my king on G3 after
quite a turn and I could play H4 and I
could open up an Avenue but not really
because you just leave it there and I
trade on G5 and I'm not I I don't think
arena is really going to be able to uh
forcibly somehow even even if I do get
uh F4 I suspect somehow the king is not
going to go to E4 and it's not going to
uh like let me just imagine the worst
for just a moment I'll probably put the
worst position on the board for Nana so
she's allowing essentially everything
if if yeah and still but hold on I can
use the pawn as a decoy okay B6 and B7
so is your goal to go King F5 King G6
yes okay that is that's precisely my
goal uh to try to invade
um
so how would you do this you would go
back right I could be 86 actually
ah
what you're going to Checkmate me when I
King E6 that's a very good move because
my intention of B6 and using the pawn as
a decoy is going to be met by King East
yeah I don't even think even if I get my
king to E4 in the best of circumstances
I don't think that she'll be able to uh
breakthrough right uh back over to you
Almera it's a day of draws a drawfest
not yet and I wanted to warn you because
I really think that F4 in this position
is a huge blunder and computer agrees
with me because you forget that after
you put your Bishop on F3 and it doesn't
really matter yes how do you maneuver
here you have to watch out for this idea
because I will play A6 first let's say I
will make a move king of six I will play
A6 first and then I will play B6 that's
nice and you know that's why your King
has to uh to watch his work yes for this
breakthrough all the time and then you
can bring your king so uh this is the
move that you shouldn't make in any
circumstances I think I I wanted to show
you another way to lose the game which
is you can
make a very natural movie for it doesn't
lose anything yet so for example
I tried F3 here and then I said okay
what's more human than to centralize
your king and you play King E5 but as
you can see this is losing once again so
instantly yes you have to be really very
careful so if you take here and if you
take Bishop F5 for example I have the
same idea of this breakthrough so I will
play first A6 you know and then I will
you will have to bring your king closer
to the bomb but then B6
so you still have to be quite precise in
this end game and maybe after F3 well
you can take
it takes F3 Bishop F3
and you have to keep your king closer to
those bus pounds
B6 idea is the one trick that white has
yes it's a goody goody though yeah you
have to be very careful again uh we do I
think we're going to be seeing a
repetition shortly in the game between
Anna and Elizabeth as they figure out a
way and I think I think they found it
they found it of going to and fro so
that they can make a three move
repetition and is it hanski I for those
of you who missed the opening of the
show uh I'm not going to say it was
hilarious because in some ways it was
hilarious that in other ways it was
painful uh the game of yesterday Anna
was two pawns up against Bella in a rook
ending cruising to Victory and a victory
it was
so Anna had come into the studio
proud of herself very nice she wanted a
very nice game and I'm there
interviewed her and said Anna you missed
something you missed something can you
spot it and I Anna came into the studio
and this was her reaction welcome Anna
I think we had the reveal
[Laughter]
yes and I just saw the move aruke three
I showed her because hopefully she
didn't see it during the game I didn't
see of course I would play something
but even after he played yesterday
I was I was looking at all kind of
stalemates and here like in this moment
and I saw this ideas like
oh well congratulations
[Laughter]
congratulations on your on your Victory
Anna I was like what kind of victory was
that and we do have a draw in uh the
second draw of the round and the first
for us we we're so used to victories and
decisive results uh we're paying by the
second result yes so it's a it's okay to
have one day of trust right I'm sure
most of the time we'll still have a lot
of the size of games exactly and we're
gonna go to a commercial break and we'll
see you on the other side
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone this is wgm a former US
Women's Champion Sabina foyer I'm very
excited to be here in San Luis at the
Third Edition of the Karen's cup I'll be
taking over San Luis chess club social
media accounts so please if you want to
interact with me and see more behind the
scenes actions and videos of the players
be sure to follow San Luis chess club's
social media accounts
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone we have two
results so far two draws between Toronto
Valley conero and tatonski pets and a
number of other games that seem to be
heading in that same garage direction we
have been
spoiled by a very very large number of
decisive games in fact four out of five
games per round thus far have been
decisive but we've already got two draws
and several others we're going to jump
to the game of Uh custom yoke for just a
moment because she's our tournament
leader she's playing the black pieces
she's a pawn down but actually with her
two Bishops with the fact that White's
King
the Knight on F1 is pinned to the King
on G1 this long-term pin is actually
given
black an advantage and there's always
the possibility that the bishop can can
steal down to the B2 Square pick up the
spawn on A3 now what white is doing is
saying hey this is spawn on H4 might be
playing G5 Queen takes H4 to maintain my
extra Pawn but the strange part about
this position is a single misstep and
basically we we've seen a repetition
thus far by the way but a single misstep
could cost white the game definitely if
black manager still grabbed the A3 Pawn
with the bishop and then B4 Pawn Falls
as well as well black has a pass Pawn on
a a file and in fact uh Almera as we
were on on break in coming to uh the
game you were saying be careful there's
a way to lose this position as black
right away show our viewers
I just simply wanted to show you that
even after they moved the teleplayed
here so let's say Bishop B5 there was
Queen G5 well you can simply play King
G7 okay
if you take the spawn nh4 your queen is
uh well absolutely out of the board here
yeah you can put it here so now you can
start and grab these pants and push and
push your a pound so this position as
you can see is already much much better
for black so you can't take the bone and
H4 so you have to find a way simply to
wait but this is probably the most
unpleasant thing for me in chess and I
especially against the two Bishops you
don't know at some point you lose
patience and you
go for something and that's where you
lose the games so this idea that you
have to defend passively for a long
period of time it's very very difficult
for everybody actually
so I think maybe you can try Queen A3
here but here Bishop B2 is winning the
A3 pound and once again black has
achieved a lot in the last five ten
moves whereas white actually hasn't
achieved anything this this pin on the
on the first rank is really very awkward
but that's what they got so two wide's
defense they don't need to achieve
anything they need to passively defend
which is very hard to do very very hard
to do so possibilities of our tournament
leader uh increasing her lead or can she
goes this off that'll be three out of
three not bad or could I maintain the
position we'll keep that game
another game that we've been keeping our
eye on and this game of Bella she's been
upon down but she's achieved something I
think which is rather significant her
I want to say potential past Pawn on the
queen side that is to say black has this
idea of a palm breakthrough she wants to
play C3 and after B takes C3 to play B3
right sneak upon uh up the board the
extra pawns that white is in White's
possession the pawns on e4 and E3
doubled and blockaded so they're not
really doing white any great favors
whereas C3 is serious sorry black pieces
are absolutely perfect
trying to improve black species
see how you could right exactly we have
a very very strong player
in the Northwest area Seattle his name
was Robert Zuck three letters Zed UK
zuke lobzook and he was a very very
strong master and he would put his
pieces on the best squares and that was
called the zoo point he reached the zoo
point then he didn't know what he was
supposed to do he just put his face so
Black's pieces are ideally placed but
then you know you got to have a
breakthrough but in this case the
Breakthrough is very obvious if it was
Bella's turn
C3 is on her agenda so for example if we
scoop upon Rook takes A3 this is what
Bella is uh
thinking about can I I thought that
Black's idea was if survived to take on
A3 and get the Rook on B2
because I still get to have a pass Pawn
on the C file
without sacrificing I don't know which
one's better but so something something
like this uh check uh where am I
supposed I I don't have a choice
actually
C3 okay
um I didn't know which
Pawn was the most dangerous right you
can't go wrong I wanted to go Rook C5
but I do see you've got a sneaky on E5
my Pawn promotes at the end so oh
this is this is wicked as well I funnily
enough I didn't I I I I I had a
different uh Blinder you know sometimes
you see one idea and you you discount
others but this is also when you say
good move look for a better one Michael
top Michael yeah uh yeah if you see a
good move stop think look for a better
move before playing the good move
I recently heard during one of the
either
some structure and anishikiri said that
that old advice he doesn't believe in
that he said you see good movie make it
yeah just go for it
practical play now yeah now now right
but uh this is also and that is why
white is stopped the move Rook beef b-8
froze uh because if I'm not taking on A5
oh
but A4 how am I keeping things closed B3
so if I take in Rook C5 you still have
Rook B2 hmm
um yeah and you sorry once again just
tell me I mean I I don't even see how
I'm dealing with this Pawn I mean if I
come back
I mean this is not exactly my dream boat
position right three
or Knight D1 might be better not sure
but 90 D1 might be better yeah that is
true okay and King's coming to D3 next
move that is kind of true yeah
um good point okay so you're you're
taking on C3 and Rook B2 probably is
more delicate delicate
uh black somehow is for Choice Almira uh
Bella is playing
good chess suddenly really good chest
and they have a very interesting
variation for you in this position
because I wanted to try more human aid
for it here as Nazi suggested and C3 I
think is well a very human try indeed
here so the computer doesn't like btx C3
because he thinks that after B3 black is
even well not even but much better yes
after this so play B2
Rook B1 then Knight C4
Knight D1 is losing after Rook G8
so this yes this position
so but there is a very interesting
variation along the way so after C3 yeah
well you play what did they analyze here
C3 Knight D3 Knight D3 here so Knight C4
right
B3
so Knight D2 wow yes Rook A5 Knight B3
yeah Rook B5 and you think that actually
black is winning
because after taking you're taking B5 I
can play C2 okay
no no no the computer says B6
and if you don't make this only move
Knight A5 here you're actually losing if
you dare to promote
sorry just a king D7 looks good yeah
King G7 is E5
is important but if you're there to
promote here yes you're actually losing
wow and then B7 nice so Knight loses
against the two pawns P6 and E5 wow yeah
nice that's that's how I spend my days
in this video
well I love chess right it was a
beautiful variation uh which goes to
say that out of the three games
remaining this game has the best chances
of maybe a decisive result whereas in
the game between Arena and uh let's say
Alexandra also has some chances that is
true too definitely Bella's playing for
a win
right and in this game of Arena that
this was the problem I just didn't see I
mean Black's King for for for reasons of
uh upon breakthroughs whether it be
Asics and B6 or directly B6 Black's King
is more or less stuck
the black king has to stay
on uh the queen side and I was about to
say the only pathway up the board is E4
and so long as the bishop patrols that
uh is where it's hard to get there she
plays
commentators curse but she does it with
a purpose right it is a Tempo against
the pawn if we drop back with the bishop
we could then uh come back Bishop D3
here and then we go back oh I see so I'm
waiting for you this yes but maybe I can
go around King F3
King F3 give me your Pawn oh no then you
can well can you me
that's interesting it could be a bit of
a race in that case probably I should be
more
[Music]
um
what can I do sorry Bishop here King F3
probably I I'll wait
so I'm waiting for you to step to the E4
Square so I can go here and if I go King
G4 I know ah
what are we just exchanging pawns no I'm
taking two you're taking two well that's
what I'm trying to do
that is not good
okay Financial six you don't want to
play G4 no I don't want to play in in
into any of this strangely enough I
thought that black was keeping
um it was hold on I got thrown off here
just a second here she played the move
Bishop F7 I thought why didn't she just
keep her Bishop on this diagonal so I'm
thinking the moment you go here well you
can't keep it right because white oh
that's the idea okay right you should
have that yes
okay uh
um let me go back to the current
position Let me refresh my board and I
think Nana
made an inaccurate move because she
moved the king
now I can go so if I go back to the line
A6 right we have to go King C7 and this
is a6b 90 threatening Beast I have no
choice I have to go kids
uh Mara we've got a breaking alert here
we think Nana is given Arena a golden
opportunity well I told you so always
watch out for this move for this idea
and she's completely lost now Irina has
this A6 move at her disposal you should
always keep your king here
so King D6 is a terrible mistake so
let's have a look A6
right 67 now and now your king is moving
up to E4 and you're completely winning
there is absolutely nothing that you can
was not as mistake on move 40 was she in
time trouble uh I'm not so sure but here
no it's the 41st move yes
so for example after a bishop B2 you can
simply play uh Bishop G6 for example if
you try to go this way I think that you
can easily hold like this bishop H5 King
G3 and then you keep your king here
closer to those phones ab and then well
you can try anything you have three
let's say King C7 Bishop before King C8
I don't see that there is any way for it
to progress right to break through oh my
goodness King D6 blunder alert Oh Nana
rushed after move 40 you gave this
advice at the last tournament yes sir
that no matter what the position is take
a break get out of the board go have a
snack walk around then come to back to
the board with a fresh mind right uh the
the the person who gave me that advice
by the way was David bronstein and his
advice very was very very specific uh go
and splash cold water on your face like
he was really one of these you know like
wake up
cold water towel yourself off dry and
then come back and you're like you know
somebody just slapped me in the face and
woke me up King D6 oh my gosh that
tiredness uh long game uh just uh I
think she just relax
yeah to be honest I think that she
forgot about this idea that's the only
winning idea in this position right do
we think Irina has already seen it oh
yes oh yes I I I mean that's the one
thing that she's setting herself up for
is that pawn breakthrough and by the way
just remind me who are predictions were
because I mean I so far I've been on
cruise control
with uh Alexandra but somebody yeah
I thought somebody had Arena on their
list
or a social media director she's in the
know and if you want to be in the know
uh stay uh subscribe to the social media
channel Samina is doing a lot of uh
behind the scenes definitely uh she
caught me the other day yeah yeah during
the break right yeah during the break
yeah there's a lot of behind the scenes
very interesting interviews short clips
photos everything that you can see on St
Louis chess club social media accounts
both Instagram and Twitter yeah
definitely stay tuned but this is this
is huge and for
for arena you know one of the lowers I
think she's the second lower seed right
coming in difficult to believe right I
mean as the underdog like hello I asked
her about that by the way I said Arena
when was the last time that you were
Underdog in a tournament she said the
Karen's cup
okay
I asked and answered wow what an
opportunity and I'm telling you she is
she I think she's getting nervous
because she's she's very aware that the
move A6 but she wants to be absolutely
certain because you play a move like A6
and if there's some trick in the
position that you haven't quite seen
again we're looking so she's saying yeah
if you step back with your king I get it
I I win on the spot with King E4 but
what do I do
yeah if you don't step back with your
King what if I what if I go Bishop E8
well E6
we take it Bishop F3
oh Bishop F3 you meet oh wait a minute
you could still play A7 true yes I'm
sorry I know I had it in my mind that I
was playing E5 E4
you know so I was like oh A7 Bishop
Bishop E4 and and there's a prop no
there's nothing
don't don't
uh no that's just it that that Bishop E8
is not even close but just B6 uh kills
it so there's nothing there's no
variation A6 you have to play games
yeah we always get that question what is
more important studying openings or end
games end games end games always fun
games and games because
what does it behoove you
to play a beautiful opening get a
long-term advantage blunder the ending
like what did you achieve happens so
often right you can play beautifully for
first 30 40 moves and then you get an
equal end game one inaccurate move it's
over and you're done uh wait uh let's
check with John Saya Bella's game
because uh Josiah played Knight D1 I
think one of the critical position here
she did not go for Rook takes A5 which
we looked at she did not go for A4 she
played the move Knight D1 sorry Ken
black create a passport like you wanted
to with C3 and B3 absolutely the other
thing that actually uh flashed through
my mind C3 and B3 becomes Knight B2 but
I can take on A3 now yeah that was the
other thing that flashed through my mind
is taking on A3 uh this is pretty nasty
that's a that's that's a setup that we
would like right and your point earlier
that in night and games Corner Pawns
are much stronger applies here too
indeed another manifestation of the old
canards that outside passed ponds
overwhelm nights
um we're seeing some pretty uh I I mean
it in the word attractive uh break Pawn
breakthroughs in this round uh Almera
and after the move Knight D1 our Spidey
senses are tingling is there opportunity
uh yesterday I wanted to show you
something uh really surprising please
have a look at the evaluation of this
position ultimately a little bit only a
little bit better and then I tried a
very simple human move C3 C3
instantly
through the roof this is how important
it is uh to trust your own abilities
your own skills and that's actually an
advice that I wanted to give the amateur
players so uh resist the temptation to
analyze with the computer all the time I
think nothing can replace books and how
important it is to study middle games
and the end games so after C3 black is
winning I think so let's have a look so
what happens after B takes C3 then
and as they pointed out that you can
take on A3 well and after Rook A5 Knight
C4 with the Tampa yes so and now
okay four attacking the night well you
have this very important move Rook B5
why because well you threaten Rook A5
nice it's a very nice move so here what
happens if you take the Knight you will
play Rook A5 and whites can't sacrifice
night or the rules I know it's an
example stop me if you can but that's a
very beautiful variation so let's have a
look if
white has another Choice after
C3 so after eight takes before it's very
easy two of course simple so
um C3 I think it's completely winning
but it really surprises me that
just a move before so how important it
is also to work in a mode of retro
analysis
sometimes the algorithms are not perfect
and well here there might be a small
back actually so it's like after C3
I can I cannot find the move
even it's just that simple you had asked
me to do a Yoda and I'm going to say
Almera
feel the force
it's not just about the chess engines on
there feel the force well
okay yeah no I mean C3 is very very
natural in Arena find she played Asics
five minutes we went from three drug
games to two completely winning games
Bingo you were absolutely right and boy
I would love to see I've seen the
reaction on Nana after a7a6 yes sir you
react I'm
and she did play it Irina found a six
and I'm sure she knows it's winning and
just looking at uh the camera there in
the World Chess Hall of Fame playing
haul
stop you know just stop start oh oh oh
realization that somebody don't think
yeah it starts Dawning like B B5 B6 and
she is uh twirling the pawn who has
talked about the bad habits right the
bad habits of
yeah holding uh the Pawns in your hands
or pieces
did you ever have uh that bad habit of
twirling the pieces Almira
um not that I can think of I was
actually thinking
um of a historical image if I could
compare this position to something then
actually that's what I wanted to share
has nothing to do with chess but I think
the Hannibal has crossed the outside and
um I think that now as it's
well I wanted to praise irina's play in
this game because
she played in a way where she deprived
Nana of any counter play the opening
Choice than the middle game and even
though the end game was not perfect nana
got impatient and I think this can
explain the error in the in the end game
in the very very end
I saw that a kind of cute picture in the
b-roll as we were coming on Elizabeth
had her feet tucked under her under her
on her seat and I remember
it was off Anderson
had the same he would almost a Lotus
like position put his feet
on his chair and brought back memories
it makes you comfortable or something
right but A6 that that that that's it
that's that that's a winner and
Alexandra she's gone she's going for the
a pond no repetition because there was
uh an offer by white here Bishop E5
Queen G5 Bishop F6 Queen F4 Bishop E5
want to draw no no no no no no no no
let's play on uh Bishop C3 and it's very
clear that black is willing to to part
with her H Pawn
yeah happily happily so long as she gets
to go Queen takes A3 and queen takes B4
then it's the apron Express
and uh like you said we were thinking
that it might be a draw fast with five
games suddenly we've got two decisive
games could it be three here as uh our
tournament leader
hold on let me catch up sorry uh did she
go back we took Queen age six she went
Bishop F6 so she could have just
captured the pawn why didn't she
yeah 23 I think white has Bishop D5
threatening Queen G6 can you defend it
sorry say that again please when Bishop
wasn't C3 yeah one move back okay so
here you're suggesting Queen takes A3
sorry Queen takes A3 Bishop this is
right disturbs her that she's
threatening Queen from A3 cannot defend
G6 exactly upward placement thank you
that definitely clears uh the cobwebs
there you're absolutely can black Play
Bishop D3 here
there's Queen E3
23 double attack yeah
this and you're not getting the nice
harmonic uh
play that you want so that's why she
played Bishop F6 a lot of chewing and
throwing
um Amira but I feel that Alexandra is
making progress
it's very important to her King on G7
maybe she realized it now so she went
back Bishop F6 and if let's say queen F4
you should try King G7 in this position
and then you can play on so all the
ideas with Bishop D5 and queen takes G6
they they do not exist anymore exactly
with the kingdoms yes it's very
important so let's see if you can play
G5 here right I tried Bishop B2 uh after
what else yes after Queen H4 then you
can take on A3 Bishop H3 A3 and okay you
can come back but what I don't like
about this move G5 that this is also
becoming an additional Target
because your pieces are still 10 gold
here and well you can come back unless
we can try something
yes then
maybe bishop E5 here so I don't know
Queen A3 and well you have to find a way
to progress from here I see not so easy
not so easy for Alexandra still a lot of
hard work in store for her in the game
of Arena where after A7 pardon me A5 A6
um Nana is Frozen just Frozen she's
she's come to grips with the fact that
oh my God she's gonna have to go King C7
allow the white king to go to E4 she's
losing the pawn and then it's just
too straightforward that there's nothing
to discuss so once more if you have a
situation like this this this
uh all Arena needs to do is just pause
she's know it no hurry the king cannot
allow uh B6 so there's no way to defend
King takes E5 and she can have her cake
and eat it too in this case uh King
takes E5 is an easy easy winning ending
and I wouldn't be
too surprised of Nana
said okay I blew it this this is a
losing moment uh go back to the Bella
game for a second Bella's taking her
time after 91 because we're on move 41.
she just got uh 30 minutes she's been I
think thinking for a while she's down to
12 minutes I think
I don't know never mind 18 minutes they
put the clock in like two point tight
I mean I'm sure they're trying to early
blindness in my days
don't hate that uh but yeah but now you
see the bird's eye view of the clock
there and uh 17 minutes and it is a
critical moment she has to play C3 in
order to play for a win exactly now we
spoke about that coming on the show
earlier losing a game harsh harsh harsh
beat yourself up everything's okay
losing a second game now that really
takes away a lot of self-confidence and
hurtful hurtful the third game then you
start questioning life itself the energy
matter and everything else so Messiah is
young but yeah it's still hurts
three in a row uh and with white I think
two of her games were with white out of
three wow so something uh see this is
not going well I'll Mira jump in have
you ever lost three games on a trot that
it it's it's a terrible thought right
well I think I had even a more traumatic
experience I lost five games in a row
yes when I was a kid in uh well in one
of the Championships and then and while
I bounce back with five wins I don't
know right but I wanted to ask you as
yes sir is this still valid when you get
married normally you're supposed to lose
50 points 50 rating points so Jean Saya
just recently got married and this is
her I think her first tournament uh
since her wedding right well that was
what they said in the 50s I thought in
Modern Age it should be something closer
to 40 rating points well I don't know
get married I wanted
I wanted for every rule there is an
exception how about yourself and Elmira
what's your experience uh how many
rating points did you lose well actually
at that time I remember I actually was
studying at the surfboard so I wanted to
finish my studies but then a lot of
tournaments a lot of new tournaments
appeared on the chess scene because we
didn't have the world championship there
which had another format so it appears
so I had to drop my studies and then I
went on winning the European
championship and I was qualified for so
many tournaments so that didn't apply to
me as well so two exceptions though
right I probably made up for you both
but never mind never mind but they have
the second marriage
wow I love Springs Eternal uh let's go
uh to the game of Bella so if I'm in
white shoes and uh Knight D1 and you
play a C3
it's my job to make your Victory as
difficult as possible so even though we
know what's coming up I I don't want to
see the move c3c2 I have to take uh you
don't want to play B3 because you allow
me to blockade but you do want to take I
do want to take you do want to play
Knight C4 how diff this move to my mind
I mean and it's difficult it's not that
that's not an easy move to find but is
it the only move though because I am not
threatening King D3 but anyway
that's the key right I'm not threatening
Rook C4 yet but I I may be threatening
Rook A6 and King D3 so because of that
maybe I can play Rook d8
Rook David eight okay by the way we have
a move on the board and Bella I think so
and Bella did not play C3 she played oh
she prepped it with the whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa she
she's allowing
King D2 maybe yeah exactly or take on I
don't know if I should take well if I go
a b a b king D2 haven't I just done
myself a great service by by stopping
your pawns from breaking through uh
no the move Rook C8 that was a mistake
that she she she missed an opportunity
there
Rook C8 excuse me Rook CA King a b
so now her
her next room is very clear it's C3 so
of course is going to play King D2
whether with a takes before or without
right but then how does black create a
passport right well the reason why I
threw in King D2 was just because I was
fearful that uh I I the the still
uncomfortable yet exactly this Pawn
especially with the Knight coming to C4
I would I do have King C2 here but we
still don't want to allow it right yeah
I I would rather not so a b would be my
choice a b a b King C2 and I would be
king D2 I'd be breathing a sigh of
relief actually for sure blood cannot
create a passport however I do have an
open a file so let's try it okay eight
maybe there's something there
well again just a a sense of relief that
I can do this right to D3
okay so you you obviously you know
you're zoning in on the action here I
don't want to play B3 and allow Rook
check so can I disturb you Shaq
I want to go up yeah King A5 okay gift
me the pawn on C4
Rook to C6 I I don't want to take the
pawn on G6 I feel like as as soon as I
allow Rook A2 and Knight B2 I'm gonna be
crying you know like yeah if I can't
keep see for
Thief alive then I'm losing all my
winning chances again right these Rook
endings I really don't think is anything
well maybe I even have Rook C2 but never
mind I'm just saying this Rook ending I
really feel like
you know yeah exactly exactly so we're
thinking
um
zataya just uh stare death in the face
and uh got a reprieve uh
Almera is that true
well it's not over yet because the
position is still a slightly better for
uh black homicide
only slightly better but this is the
variation that you analyzed like it
takes before it takes before let's say
native two I think we were trying King
D2 most
then I like the computer's proposed of
Knight D3 okay
group B5
you have to offer once again a human
perspective on this position because of
course it's minus uh one so the position
is much better for black but it's simply
because first of all you have absolutely
nothing to do your pieces are paralyzed
and there are a lot of thicknesses so
you know said so I think that black can
play on for for an hour here do not
compromise the position and then try
something in the time travel
okay play on for an hour we used to say
play on forever
I can make a simple move Rook d8 then
well should you go King
E2 back because if you go for example
King C2 then I can play 91. and I can
take a few pounds you know it's strange
I'm not so afraid of you taking my ah
yeah I was about to say I would probably
be willing to trade the G2 Pawn for the
B4 Pawn but the move B3 okay
um what's going on and why do you need
to play Rook C5 Rook C5 so we can't
no yeah this is still looking pretty
dangerous for white well but
what was that takes King D2 and 93 93
rugby five Rook D A King C2 91 check and
just a second I mean I'm not afraid of
uh of this your spawns are stuck I
should be afraid of this well
I see behind Almira the one line is -2
the other one is Checkmate in seven so
then I'm worried
should you try the move King 2 here
okay at least it looks
because here the computers yes he offers
Knight C1 then King 193 so this is less
obvious for him so and here you simply
wait Rook D6 so you need to make another
useful move do you have a useful move in
this position Rook p8 or something yeah
okay so let's try Rook B8
and what does he think he waits can he
make your move for example Rook A6
nicely because he doesn't suggest this
and I like it but unfortunately yes you
have this Knight F2 here just well in
the trade for the B2 B4 pump pardon me
um but even here take on F2 and then B3
are you in the C4 Pawn okay by the way
one of the extraordinary things is black
is dominating a pawn down yeah that is
so weird right it's because it's the
double pawns and Plex King is fantastic
in the center yes
the passive Knight on D1 the passive
king and the clock times uh since they
recently reached 40 they still have a
lot of time uh jeansai has 25 minutes
and Bella almost 15. oh
very good back to the game of arena for
just a moment because once again since
the move A6 Nana has just
froze it's like
I mean this this horrible realization
because it comes over you in several
ways at first you're disbelieving like
no that can't be right
then it's like this you know acceptance
five stages right right of grief right
you know and then and then you need a
recovery you know and oftentimes it's
happened to me at the board that I
literally look at my score sheet and I
go
where did where did I go wrong yeah
exactly yeah in a situation like this
where you just made a big blunder I
think it's better if you have little
time on the clock so at least it'll be
over soon exactly now she has time to
sit there and feel the cruelty of what
has just taken place as uh Arena's King
is going to waltz up the board and bring
her Victory a victory that might get her
tied for first based upon the result of
Alexandra what's going on there Elmira
well Alexandra started with King G7 her
opponent played G5
and then this is the position which we
have on the board after Bishop F5 and
actually I found a way to defend this
position but and I have an interesting
variation for you here so as you know
you shouldn't take the pawn on H4 it's
very dangerous but let's say I will play
Queen E3
Bishop B2
then I wanted to play uh Queen F4
and if you take Bishop A3 I have a
surprising move but which makes a draw
Bishop D5
yes
so Queen F1 King H2
Bishop E8 but after Queen F6 there is a
Perpetual because it doesn't matter
where you go so if I will give a check
here and if you go here then I can take
the pawn on G6 what if I went to H7
after Queen F6 check yes let's check
this one so queen of six chairs just
King H7
yeah temporarily the bishop on a even
though I have a full move here there's
nothing I can do yes let's try well this
is this is the purpose
the problem is Queen takes creases you
can try Queen G3 so you protect the the
pound on G6 but then you take an eight
you can take on B4 no but yeah yes but I
mean this is extremely difficult to find
yeah but desperate desperate uh yeah I
wanted to say that by the way both
players have been fighting in a sense
that Alexandra wants to eat the queen
side ponds but she doesn't want to give
up the kingside pawn
good night wants to take the H4 upon so
I think it would be very hard for uh to
say no I I don't want to eat the pawn on
h4a I have to play passively with the
move on queen queen E3 once again if she
does take on H4 right here in this exact
moment does the engine go berserk and
say oh now it's lost it's over oh not at
all it's still about equal but I think
it makes things easier for black well
maybe I can take we can take take the
pound on A3 is it the same idea Bishop
D5 with the idea of playing Queen H6 and
exactly yes maybe I can try something
like this looks a bit artificial but the
whoa it's no one well in this case
though I go Queen H if if I saw Queen H4
Queen A3 Bishop D5 I would say let's go
I've got play I've got play I mean I
I've won a pawn and maybe on a good day
I even get to play H4 H5 in the future
uh lifetime but Queen takes H4 is there
something besides you can play Bishop D3
anticipating all this ideas and you can
take on a three on the next move so this
is almost looks like an improvisibility
yes yeah so it's like a waiting move
because I don't have Bishop D5 now right
do I have an useful move
no you have to move your queen let's say
you can play Queen G4 but now you can
take an A3 but that's better because now
white doesn't have that Queen H6 idea
right exactly yes but now your knight
can move so I'm not sure if after Knight
E3 and if I give you a check can you
play Bishop F1 and exchange that's a
little bit of a relief though right
you know like I've given myself yes
thank you King G2 that's what that's
what it's been all about the fight and
she took the pawn uh both players took
the ball yeah
I'm gonna have to hand out some more
memberships but this is it this is the
moment Bishop D5 by gunai with the idea
of Queen H6 and queen takes G6 is
probably the best opportunity she's
gonna have can she start with Queen H6
check just so black king cannot run to
f8 okay that's a good question Queen H6
uh King G8 is force now you want to say
Bishop 35 I think there's a difference
though here right oh Queen D3 I mean
talk about a triple I defend G6 yeah I
hit F1 and I hit D5 what a triple
and by the way uh Arena let's jump to
that game because uh we have seen
yes she did everything perfectly uh that
is to say put her Bishop on F1 and uh
we're about to see captures on G4 I
thought H4 was better and just take on H
I beg you pardon course you're you're
right 100 H4 is at the the winning move
why excuse me completely H4 and you're
just gonna
start both of those bonds yeah start a
complete Harvest on the king said okay
sorry let's do this again uh you show me
I I'm going to go
Bishop E8
okay maybe bishop D3
you know what I was trying to do was I
was trying to get you to play King G5 so
I would put my Bishop on F7 but you can
go Bishop to E3 yes and just directly
very simple very simple
no I somehow I don't have maneuvering
room I wanted to the diagonal is too
short or something I want to be able to
put my Bishop on F7 nope you once you
play Bishop G6 H4 is on the board but
once you play Bishop D3 the bishop to G6
that's it that that is going to win the
game
yeah block has no ideas here left at all
about that was unexpected because Nana
equalized uh well they had a very sharp
opening if you remember
but then she equalized really well
Knight got to D4 in the end game and
then it was just one move King D6 where
she rushed on move 41. wow and it costed
her the game yes
um again I want to jump back to our
tournament leader Alexandra's game we
have a queen on D3 no but there was no
Queen H6 so yeah just a second I think I
should uh I should refresh my board for
just a moment
that's what I have on my board
yes I think
here we go 2023 yes
so she went Bishop to D5 correct move
Queen to D3 now white has Knight E3 and
that's the difference she can jump with
the Knight to E3 and
that is a kind of thing relief Alexandra
needs to start running with the King
right King f8
okay
um
by the way yeah okay fine King f8
you know I'm
I would just love this opportunity to
seize this opportunity and put my king
on G2 but I'm I'm also you're giving me
the the the opportunity to play either
Queenie for
or no Bishop C4 I don't know if I want
to give up the diagonal should I go
Queenie for here though uh
probably
I mean you're not losing upon right if I
take in Bishop F4 you just play H4
o is very very happy to play this knife
hasn't moved since the opening right I
mean once the Marshall uh appeared on
the board the Knight appeared on F1 and
hasn't moved and uh well most of the
again but yeah the whole game uh so 93
on the board as well and king of Fate
um since Queen H6 isn't a threat I don't
know if I played the move
what do you like yes sir I know exactly
what do I like them I'm I'm torn between
Bishop D6
and Bishop D4
I I don't see the threat behind Queen H6
for the time being so if I play Bishop
D4 let's just be careful with Bishop D4
okay I have Knight F5 check
I didn't see it first of all I did not
see that Knight F5 check my gosh could
that turn the tables completely around
if I tap the queen yes if you take with
the queen queen before and
why it's an extra upon it but if I take
with the pawn queen H6 I go back Queen
G6
Bishop takes off seven wait no I'm not
taking with the bishop uh I have Queen
H5 check
with another check so it has to be made
right yes King AJ Queen H5 and there's
your queen F7 and queen G8 lovely well
done nice oops Knight F5 uh boy that was
a
that was a blind spot
I mean
the Dutch have a beautiful word
varossing surprise harassing Knight F5
check didn't see that coming the bishop
D4 would be
an error actually 93 on the board how is
the situation at this moment I I have
the feeling that uh
that Alexandra's let
her opponent slip a little bit slip away
and Arena has won her game
beautiful game
well beautiful end game definitely but
for Nana I mean
that hurts
that hurts a lot she probably felt safe
the entire game and then all of a sudden
it's over indeed our second
well what am I saying our first win
right yes today it's our first win we
had two draws earlier because between uh
Journal Valley and conero zato and pets
and Irina Crush just defeated Nana that
needs them
and at the moment she's at South first
place that she's got two and a half
points of course custom you could join
her with a draw
and even surpass her with a win but for
the moment I really crushed and clear
first and uh and well that moved 93 I
think that really is one of those
moments where you say the worst is over
and you kind of feel like the draw is in
sight after you get to play your first
active move in a very very long time
unless they reach second time trouble
then anything can happen
is there a second time not yet not yet
because then they're just going to be
playing on their increments for the rest
of the game that that's uh it and Bella
how is Bella doing uh didn't take on B4
there's no pawn exchange so she just
played candy too and her reasoning is
that she likes the option of Rook takes
A5 so after King D2 were considered in
C3 check right and I was thinking
instead of Roxy six one move back oh
pardon me yeah C3 check I was thinking
that the reason why she wasn't afraid of
series reject could it possibly have
something to do with kids loses a pawn
right she takes BN Knight C4
C takes B and Knight C4 right
okay pause pause pause pause
because somehow I'm I'm not feeling it
at the moment you're not going to take
with the Knight
on A3 because A5 is hanging right so if
I if I hang where should I hang
okay well my hook is coming in on the
second rank so I might take with the
Knight you might take with the Knight
but aren't I kind of munching my way to
a draw here it does look that way right
so perhaps she was fearful of Kings he
won we've been pounding the table play
C3 play C3 just about into any moment
she played the move Rook C6 he's been
awfully patient yes maybe too much so to
be a pharaoh it's not like white can do
anything except wait but why it's
improving the king I can't move King C2
so C3 doesn't come with a check
absolutely that's uh in fact that's a
huge benefit just to get out of those
tempos and especially the night also
coming to the C4 Square when I a rook is
is conveniently placed on A5 sorry do
you think
do you think wow okay that's a
completely different kettle of fish
wow
wow it's forced to exchange because if
you take on A5 there is B3 yep that that
is probably uh
bad news
I'm just uh three something yeah exactly
Knight D3 and
something
like E1 I was about to go yeah oh yeah
you can yeah at night at fortnite E1
yeah this is definitely not Joy
um so the you you you were asking me
about the night ending
um
uh a b a b yeah it's hard to believe
that with an extra Pawn white could lose
this true but these pawns are basically
keeping my king and
maybe maybe it's better wow wow we're
saying uh
black has been a pawn down for the
better part of 20 moves and in enjoying
an advantage ever since you don't
usually hear those words
uh put quite like that but definitely
Bella is in the driver's seat even in
this ending so you're right Rook D6
could be and she just played it
on her agenda sorry I was just
refreshing my board and she has played
with D6 going for that night ending
um
wow yeah I'm uh I'm again maybe white
needs to exchange on D6 okay exchange on
B4 okay
so far so good I really want to force
more exchanges
yeah allowing C3 yeah I want to set up a
fortress here so what you want to do is
you want to be able to have access to
the square D3 yeah but I don't have it
right
exception 9g4 am I losing I have to we
have to calculate the pawn and then who
is in zuktuan well no I'm gonna I I
don't want to count 93. picking up all
your pawns oh am 9g2 Knight H4 I'm
losing all of them aren't I I thought I
was going to get uh something back but
maybe you're right I'm just losing
oh dear no I think you're right I think
that that is uh
so B3 C3 sorry so take me through it
again so I don't know how to set up a
fortress right okay so let's say I go
here you go here yeah just go back I go
back 85. okay King D3 right and if it's
white to move I'm in zuk Swan right and
knights are very bad at losing a move
right you can't lose the move yeah you
can lose a Tempo with the bishop very
easy you can stutter step on a diagonal
Knights don't lose Tempe so you can go
back but then
I wouldn't say black isn't this one
right yeah so triangulate can you can
can you triangulate can you go like here
here or here
King E6 King D6
because you can't move your knife all
right so you have to move your king
you go here
you have to move your king
triangulation my dear
nice and nicely done thank you
so maybe Bella is Maybe This Night
ending is uh winning and we have a guest
with Almera over to you
oh yes welcome Marina once again
congratulations uh well I think that you
had winning chances yesterday as well so
what a start two and a half out of three
uh well I wouldn't call you an underdog
of course but I think that all the U.S
funds are chanting out there so yeah
hopefully I'm making my fans happy
uh so let's have a look at the game uh
can you share a little bit uh well some
secrets of your preparation why did you
start with this line yeah well it's
funny I mean I think her triangle slav
was
um a very logical idea for her
um but the thing is that I mean it
wasn't necessarily the most obvious
thing that she could do right it was
just kind of like a logical idea the
thing is though that I thought thought
about that too right because it's so
logical that you know I thought you know
she might uh do that you know avoiding
the exchange law for example
um and yeah I went for the Marshall game
but this is something I've kind of had a
liking for for a very long time you know
like you know back when I was like a
teenager you know 20 years ago and I was
studying these lines I mean I kind of
went through all the gambas the Marshall
Gambit the Geller Gambit you know like
the anti-muscow variation of the
vatvanic
um so basically I mean I kind of feel
like when black doesn't control the E4
Square it kind of makes sense to try to
play in the maximally aggressive way so
what did you expect uh what was the end
of your preparation was this yeah some
somewhere here basically
um Queen A3 Knight C5 Bishop D4 like I
knew this idea because it's actually far
from an obvious idea like the idea to go
Bishop D4 just trade on C5 and claim
some sort of an edge in the end game
because of your better Pawn structure is
certainly you know you know it's not the
most obvious thing unless the computer
shows you and also maybe a very
unpleasant choice for your opponent
because you deprived her for any like
she didn't have Dynamic play at all yeah
no it's true I mean Nana definitely
thrives in more like aggressive
positions and so like
I mean I wasn't sure how much there was
in this end game
um I feel like for me the big decision
was trading off all the Rooks right like
I don't know I it took me a while to
come up with this I don't know how good
it is but I kind of felt like it worked
out quite well
um yeah because after Bishop State I was
like okay what do I really have here
right um she's gonna go Knight D4 Pawnee
five and so I went for this trade of
everything which is definitely not like
meant to be a draw offer I mean I
expected to be pushing in this position
in a way it like removes even more of
the dynamic possibilities for black so
now you're like completely in a two
result game I mean you know white can't
really mess this up unless you know they
they just fall asleep or leave the board
you know
um but I thought like it's it's
unpleasant to play against the outside
Pawn majority I would never want to be
black and like in this position you know
it's a friend effect because they said
that you shouldn't trade all the Rooks
and you have to keep one yeah I don't
know it's like I just think yeah it was
not an obvious decision but I felt like
you know because if you're going to be
pushing your queen side pawns right the
more Rooks there are it's also the
trickier it is to push those Queen side
Pawns
that it may be yes G5 was a better move
in this position just
wait and see so were you planning on
playing before like you did in the game
yeah I mean just the general plan King
D2 before I mean the thing is like yeah
the black has to really feel the
subtleties here right like for white
again it's much easier to play I mean I
thought she played logically but then
there were a couple of things that I did
that I um I thought were interesting
like
this move G4 I mean this is yeah so in
this game I did some you know funny
things with the pawns because I wound up
putting all of them on light squares
even though I'm the one with the you
know light squared Bishops I'm kind of
like breaking the rules but I was like
oh this is very interesting because I
can fight for the E4 square right so
there were definitely some paradoxical
things going on with the pawn placements
in this game and this was one of those
decisions here I was feeling like pretty
good about my position
F5 and H3 yeah that was another one I
mean I didn't know of course taking on
F5 was tempting
um but then I decided to like not
activate that Bishop for a while I see
the engine doesn't really like my choice
but in the game I was like duh you know
I was pretty happy with it
while the engine is not always right so
let's get let's have a look at the uh
the most critical moments of this game
C5 you know it was amazing that like you
know I like to me I was amazed that I
was not like winning this end game I
mean after C5 B5 you think like those A
and B Pawn should be really dangerous
but then I realized okay it's actually
not so simple
yes and then actually that's that was
where I uh told our audience that there
is a way to lose the same game and I
wanted to illustrate it in a very simple
way because you can play let's say E4
I'm I'm amazed like you can like you can
allow them to take an F5 and play Bishop
G4 and like black is still holding that
like that's just not obvious at all of
course it's not obvious to human mind so
after I said what's more natural than
centralize your king yeah here you are
yeah you're take you're sick and then
you play A6 and it means that you always
had to watch out for this ideas so I
think that uh your opponent forgot you
know she simply lost concentration but
also I I didn't realize it until like I
really started thinking because again A6
is so counter-intuitive you're putting
yet another Pawn on the light square but
like I was like oh wow she's giving me
this opportunity to come into E4 and
here okay here we were so yeah this
position I I was getting a little
disappointed because I realized that
basically I thought her holding plan was
like let's say oh we can go one more or
move King E3 let's say well yeah I don't
know she could she had these options of
going H5 but like even Bishop F7 right
and so yeah I thought she would just
kind of go back to G6 after Bishop E2
and then the point is that when every
time I go Bishop D3 she just moves her
Bishop away and I never have King E4 and
this was like the big you know
realization of this end game that I
cannot actually use the E4 square with
my king so like how do I break through
you know this was probably the way for
black to hold because we tried this
variation let's say Bishop H5 King G3
but then the King has to stay close yeah
yeah no I mean that was going to be you
know a disappointing thing for me to
swallow that like my A5 and B5 pawns
were not gonna win me the game
and so tell me what did you feel right
here when you saw them yeah so I was
surprised by King D6 just because I
thought the King was good on C7 and I
thought she could just hold using her
Bishop but I didn't immediately like
know what was wrong with it right so
then eventually like this A6 idea came
to be and I was just like wow it seems
to work in all the lines like her King
just has to go back my king breaks
through and that's kind of it
so A6 is the meaning move and well the
rest is history there is a very
important King march
and H4
just they're finally improving my pawns
a little bit
uh everything how do you feel now do you
realize that you're leading the
tournament well no I'm feeling good you
know I feel good about this game I feel
like you know well I'm trying to play
aggressively you know it's funny that
all three of my games despite very
different openings
um you know kind of aggressive openings
they've all gone into the end game
pretty quickly right so that's just an
interesting thing
um but yeah no I'm feeling overall that
I'm playing decently you know so I just
want to keep that up
and how important it is for you once
again to
uh to be a role model you know you are
playing an American soil and well a lot
of young players are looking up to you
yeah well I definitely like to make
happy the people who root for me you
know like my students my fans like my
friends my family like I like there's a
lot of categories of people that I you
know I try to make happy with my play
thank you sir you should continue thank
you all right our congratulations Arena
very very nice as uh Arena crush and
Anna zatonski are both doing incredibly
well uh three rounds of a play and I
think we're just going to take a quick
break as we uh probably going to see
another Victor coming up as Bella is
also doing extremely well we'll see you
on the other side of our break
[Music]
thanks
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out
q-boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our results so far you have one Win
Again by Irina Crush against San Antonio
which has brought Irina into clear first
as we speak right and two draws so far
satonski pets and Toronto Valley cornero
Drew their games and the two remaining
games are very interesting and let's
jump right into them
um Amira Alexandra can she catch Arena
herb pass her
well let's have a look at Alexandra's
position I have it on the board her
opponent is still thinking and here
there is a very
um interesting tactical Motif which you
can finish the game at once
oh all right I mean it's it's it will
end in the drawers I mean of course
white were fighting for a draw for for a
while so uh let's show the position
you will tell me what Bishop takes F7
King takes F7
Queen D5 yes King is seven and queen V5
nice I I simply love this idea that 95
checks king of seven Knight C3 but here
actually white is winning it's because
right extra pounds yes
let's have a look so King F7 is uh
a bad move you have to go King six and
then Knight C3 and then first you have
to play King F5 in order to make a draw
nice I mean I even though I'm this
really really experienced Grand Master I
see it time and time again every time I
see those Royal Forks of night forking
both the king and queen simultaneously
those Royal Forks have always inspired
me that's a very pretty variation Bishop
takes F7 keeps his players are rich in
time trouble
they sure are very nice down to four
minutes and Alexandra down to three
minutes the queen D5 check provokes your
king to walk into the square
so Queen uh Queen takes B5 well Bishop
takes H7 once you see the Thematic idea
of of uh sacrificing for the Royal Fork
there's no reason why white wouldn't
want to do this right I mean she she's
can't be playing for you you showed how
how Alexandra would make a draw even
after the sacrifice but but she has to
make the very accurate King E6 can get
five moves exactly but
is she thinking well she's a pawn up
could she play for example queen of
three and say hey uh defend yourself
you've got to go Bishop E8 I assume
right right Bishop Y8 and is it
completely ridiculous to play H4 Queen
E5 oh sorry Queen E5
I thought you somehow I'm fixated on the
pawns don't ask me why Queen E5 and this
is a very different move to C2 okay did
not see that coming so she's just
okay she wants to bring our Knight to D4
maybe okay I'm a little bit lost help me
out here Knight C2 why Knight C2 the B4
pound was on priest so yeah but after
Queen F3 Bishop eight H4 I could take on
D4 but what is happening here sorry
Bishop to D3 oh Queen F3 gosh darn it I
I'm I'm having a brain freeze sorry I'm
threatening I I mean I'm looking at
Bishop D3 and I'm saying why can't I win
the Knight apologies Queen F3 is her
intention Knight C2
uh what do the what do you think of this
move Knight C2 I think objectively it's
equal but because of the time still
anything can happen in this game three
minutes versus so easy to wander from
either side right and should we jump to
Bella's game because please she had a
huge Advantage once we went on on a
break right when we when we left it it
was this very very nice move Rook D6
that Bella had played offering a night
ending where she's a pawn down that
better
that was declined but instantly blacks
pieces The Rook as well as the Knight
burst into
White's paralyzed whites completely okay
that's interesting she played Brook
check I thought she was just gonna could
you two yeah yeah I thought it was time
to harvest uh the ponds with Rook takes
G2 but she played Rook C2 Knight takes
this must be winning right because she's
she's got B2 on tap she's got E3
E5 so hoping for some counter play with
the epon epon okay it's time a factor in
this one uh yes especially for Bella she
has two and a half minutes
against five and a half minutes okay so
that's an easy three yeah that's an easy
pawn for us to scoop up I think you want
uh good move
I want to take on B2 but I could try to
play more safely with king of seven he
has played Knight takes E3 King E1 on
the board uh sorry should I play King of
seven to be safe or should I just take
on B2 you know it's funny you should say
yeah I think the I think the quiet move
King S7 just to kill the counter play
was you know because I don't know uh
Rook Jack in E6 but I like the idea of
King F7 and King E6 against Rook check
sorry you were about to say say
something but
it might be just winning two yeah here
if black had time you just sit and
calculate move by move if two is winning
that's it only two minutes she has to
just play safe and I would
I would definitely play King F7 right
but I'm it's still not completely clear
if um all counter play is gone
because white can go 94 here okay we'll
just keep a close watch on this one as
we're just going to go back to uh
Alexandra's position because guess what
it has just everything just got swapped
essentially Queen D3 and a draw is
absolutely absolutely imminent we'll go
back to Bella's game as Alexander will
be tied with Arena Crush at two and a
half points once this game is drawn Rook
takes B2 okay okay
I don't know if I will call it an
imprecision because not even sure about
that what do you say here King H6 or
King f8
I'd be a little bit afraid of I want
well I will go with H6 because if you
try for night here and night here I've
got check and I can take so yeah King H6
the question is should I be worried
about E6 or not I can always sacrifice
the night now so E6 Knight of five
because your coupons will promote
themselves yes yes and how how to
sacrifice the night exactly should I do
it right away or should I be playing
Knight G7 I'm not not sure well wait a
minute
um Amira Jump Right In Here as uh uh
time trouble makes fools of us all but
there's some counter play counter
chances for zinsaya yes indeed and I
think that you have to take the pound on
E7 immediately in this variation yes for
example I tried 97 and 96 but it seems
to be losing so Wow Let's try Knight D6
first okay so well yeah
I will
okay E7 96 or 57 yeah 98 yep Rook date
yep
then Knight F6 Knight F6 of course but
remember that after Rook f8 you have a
move anymore so we can't even sacrifice
the night that's why we should sacrifice
the night right away in the position
Knight F5 E7 Knight takes E7 Rook takes
E7 and say well let's turn the tables
around and uh how are you going to deal
with
the past pawns blacks pass thanks D1 91
right yeah only move hoping to sacrifice
it back
91 you have to play C3 here C3 yeah to
get these guys going no it takes two
nine takes a three it takes you three
and this is winning and this is the
winning end game right if you go Rook to
behind I will go Rook here and I'll use
my B Pawn as a decoy I want to play two
versus one two pass pawns versus one
pass pawn and that should be good enough
uh to win but here's the Moment of Truth
E7 immediately take that pawn off the
board Knight takes E7 don't play games
don't play Knight D6 and don't play
Knight G7 uh that's not easy because
when you see the move E7 I think many
Grand Masters would be attracted to
Knight G7 and say go ahead and earn it
the problem is there's a mating net oh
okay yes
yes precisely so in this position after
E7 we're about to see it if you go
Knight G7 thinking go ahead
earn it make make me play
um
Knight takes EA I'm not threatening
and uh draw has been agreed in the the
game of Alexandra
and that was
quite the game
yeah as Arena brings herself to plus two
and shares first place if you play G5
and Bella took on E7
a very very important
why why is decision indeed E7 Knight
takes E7 and she's back in business here
he's having Knight takes E7 Rook takes
E7 she played Rooks too Rook C2
and one more she's not at the finish
line yet after Knight D1 don't play B2
play C3
yeah it's also pretty to show that if
after Rook C2 white plays rookie 3 you
can simply take Rook taste it took takes
a three oh pardon me I was so Charmed by
this idea when I was young that two
connected past pawns on what we call the
sixth rank it was the old descriptive
notation it was worth a rook I was like
whoa you know Mind Over Matter
uh yes I think Almira has some lines for
us please I'm all right I am 91 this is
it well she finds C3 yes I wanted to
anticipate so here we played C3 and I
just wanted to tell you that B2 actually
it's the wrong pound this is already
draw
so C3 is a very important move so you
after this you know the computer
evaluates this position already is equal
Rook C7 and it's exactly Rook C7 so um
for this will be a draw so it's very
important to play C3 here right crucial
moment again
but with one minute on the clock I I
have to tell you this is a gamble it's
50 50. which one do I push for for me
one of the things that's absolutely
remarkable is despite the fact that they
oftentimes only make these decisions in
Split seconds invariably they choose the
right one just like she just did and
just like uh
not the commentator's curse but first
time not this time C3 and the the
there's a very nice
um point that if you play in this exact
position Rook to B7 and you know with
the idea that B2 oh I get to play Knight
C3 and save myself you don't play B3
three
and then I oh nice
you guys can't see me dancing in my seat
but trust me
now she's not happy
Roxy Rook A1 uh I didn't choose B1 I
wanted to be a little bit further to the
left you know so that you couldn't yeah
nice nice uh time travel no for Bella in
a minute and a half okay
but it's C3 she's she's really so close
again yesterday for those of you who
missed it Anna zatonski you know at the
Finish Line completely winning two pawns
up
puts her opponent in stalemate
and Bella doesn't exploit the moment wow
okay let's hope that for Bella's fans
that she doesn't uh uh toss it away Yes
and she'll be very happy to win with the
black pieces to begin with but any game
in this competition right that's another
thing when you play such a strong event
and you have let's say a bad game
you might play someone even stronger in
the next day so yeah that's the worst
part right you don't get an easy day no
not at all so C3
um
Amira I want to say that for said she
she has to make it as difficult as
possible for her opponent
um what's the trickiest method what what
could she do to really she has taken
immediately by the way on C3
well I tried variation that another
suggested with Rook B7 then after Rook
C1 I tried King gitsu okay to show the
possible variation on the board right
maybe you can show it uh so Knight D1 C3
Rook to B7 Rook C1 King E2 yes King E2
then now C2 yep
Knight B2 yeah Rook B1 93 and B2 here of
course because you cannot play C1
because this will be a draw so B2 wins
almost 30 like it's a pretty one let me
just get caught up with the players
because after Knight takes C3 Rook take
C3 was played Rook to B7 and just like I
was about to say uh you go after this
Pawn you you you you want to win the H4
Pawn Yeah you can also do Rook C4 yes
same idea that you want to use your B
Pawn as a decoy to grab this fellow
and it's a very simple end game the two
connected passers are unstoppable
exactly
question actually if that white Pawn
instead of A3 it was on F3 is that a
draw or is it winning true
but I've seen even the top Grandmasters
lose that end game exactly of course GNH
would be an easy draw but F Pawn right
can still be lost exactly
and the clocks are ticking as Bella is
under a minute but fortunately for her
she she she's zoning in you can see her
Focus here she knows what she's got to
do she's got to take that H4 part
[Music]
yes
she's just checking checking checking to
be doubly sure
and again it was if it wasn't for
yesterday in The Rook ending of is it
four versus two or it was actually three
versus one so it was just three pawns
the F Pawn right and the two connected
past bonds and Anna setting up the
stalemate the it would be trivial but uh
this one is just two versus one and it's
really shockingly easy uh from Black's
perspective
she is keeping an eye on the a pawn
and in the meanwhile there's no way that
uh the rook and the King can hold back
uh the uh passers
plug can also try to hold the pawn from
behind right okay and I think actually
that's the strongest idea
black Rook active I I put it over here
and I shouldn't have been probably
that's when it happened yeah but yeah
it's much better to have the Rook I
remember pal benko I still hear his
voice
yes sir Rooks belong behind past bonds
thank you thank you master benko you're
you're very wise
yeah I think uh we have this general
in-game rules and they're usually
exceptions but Rook behind the pass Pawn
is very rarely there's an exception
exactly it's always the right thing to
do truly yeah
King F2 and again what we're talking
about is you want to you you want to
keep this Pawn
um you want your Rook to to hold the
pawn there's one idea here is Super Why
So if I start with Rook H2 here okay
King G3 okay okay two okay and now
it it can't start pushing age pawn and
if you push G Pawn
okay six and then and then your king is
a little bit yeah we don't want that
that is a good point I liked whatabella
did actually she just played Rook C4
uh from the start right here go behind
the pond later yes after she
successfully pushes the king side pawns
and does not cut off her own King indeed
so you're thinking that in case of King
G3 her idea is something along yeah
along these lines right so that she
doesn't get mad with Rook check in King
back and right King is on F3 so let me
just I'm going to refresh my board
everyone set up a very nice trap here
she did yes after King F3 yeah if Bella
pushes H4 yes I think that would be a
huge mistake before
oh dear so H4 Rook B4 nice trap is it is
it is it
probably it's over right
yeah this
is looking like a draw now so wow okay
be careful maybe just yeah the first
king G5
that's right because she can go to H4 so
that's it that would be the cleanest way
to go but sorry uh let me play it are we
what's going on oh you know what I'm
trying to do oh I didn't think they
could do that yeah but are you in the
Square
I thank you okay she played Rook A4
which is also good just wait in move no
rush to push the pawn or the king so
just being very careful
right because because the idea also is
that exactly in this position your Rook
somehow it's a tickle right you you so
if I force you to move your Rook then I
don't have to worry about those
variations with Rook B4 anymore and this
and if I force you to move your King
well then you're walking into my my
um
check so King G2 on the board now I
think King
G5 looks good because on Rook B5 check
I'll go King F4
and then you'll be in the square and
everybody's happy that's that's the
simple I agree King G5 that's definitely
the way to go
King G5 very very strong yeah I think H4
even here is unclear because I can play
King H3 no sorry on H4 I still have Rook
before same ideas previously yeah
G5
gosh it goes to show that even when
you're completely winning you know
you're winning there are ways that you
can blow it and we're seeing that King
H3 by the way I have to give as inside
of the credit too because she's doing
her best to making it as awkward and as
difficult as possible for opponents you
can get four yep because we are in the
zone so we can allow Rook before now
exactly what we're talking about when we
say we're in the Square
so the idea is this Pawn is going to
promote
so what we have to do is draw a square
from the promotion to the king and if
the black king is inside the square
the black king can capture the pawn
differently I draw diagonally so I would
go from B4 to f8
I learned the triangle not the cube
really yeah so if I'm in that zone I'm
good really yeah oh my gosh boy did you
get the wrong book
yeah we I think for me it was Reuben
finds chess endings that called it the
square and that was what uh I I grew up
with how about you Al Meyer Amira was it
the square or the triangle
well it was definitely the square
what's happening right
I mean wow I mean uh what what is it uh
you were we were deprived is uh you
didn't get the right the the right
wisdom okay let me refresh uh my board
but triangle huh was that because it
works it still works it absolutely it
does but uh well I mean I always prided
myself as a chess player on the
jargon of chess the the words we use uh
the Swish and zukes and the zugz Wongs
and all of those wonderful terms and
whenever I used triangulation I thought
of it with the King right you
triangulate and when I use I'm in the
Square
thought everybody was on the same page I
mean I understood it when you said it
but yeah I I heard the triangles and
um
I think Bella is winning very
simple way now after a king F4
there's like yester was pointing out if
white plays Rook before black king is in
the zone in the square in the Triangle
all of those are correct
and there's no way to stop the black
bones now just G4 H4 are coming
I think they know it shensaya
no she's lost she's still fighting until
the end of course but
Bella must feel such a relief she's
about to win her first game in this
tournament
almirah you know that feeling after two
losses that you're about to win
describe that feeling
well first of all
um
you know when you're losing two games in
a row and especially if we take into
consideration how those two games went
you know just I'm not sure you'd trust
yourself anymore so that's why Bella is
taking her time even if she takes it up
to the last second you know she she
needs to be sure that she's going to win
this game if she's not going to mess it
up so it's it's very important for her
to uh be concentrated uh to well to till
till the very end because yesterday she
could have made a draw it was a
miraculous situation but she resigned
before
and I think that it was a very important
lesson for her even though she has so
many years of professional career behind
her shoulders right experience yeah
yeah rookie four prepping rookie three
check yeah
I agree with Almira where she pointed
out that even when you know you're
completely winning you're still not sure
because
the losing two games in a row affects
your confidence so much absolutely
so it's not over until you know alponent
resigns and you sign the score sheets
true true that's what I always say
King G2 rookie two check or just G4
G3 still works but now rookie three why
right just push G4
or okay to check I like the rookie to
check just to drive the king even
further back
yeah
so
it's incredible that she outplayed her
opponent down a pawn almost the entire
game yeah from that decision to play uh
Rook D Rook takes D3 even though yeah
G4
fortunately for sansaya
um she's all the choices are winning for
all right black she knows to not be
materialistic
your Pawn up you think that you are
better but that's not the case and I
think that Jean Saya was blindsided by
by the solution right she played for a
win where there was no win at all
yeah
um I've only played jensaya just once
but I've watched her play for many years
and she always plays for a win she's a
very aggressive player always plays for
a win and sometimes yeah you might over
push where you shouldn't
can backfire
by the way for me uh the move G4 I don't
I don't know if you had the same feeling
but for me the move G4 is a little bit
inaccurate I would have played Rook
check and just driven the king back to
the first rank you're a fan of technical
wins yes G4 rookie 2 H3 King H2 King F3
on the board uh threat alert right
rookie to check threat alert I have to
play Jack
because the three I can still play
rookie three that's the point you're
still in the school
this was fine
and black is threatening to play rookie
two I think even though I won't be in
this Square so if I go A4
Rook takes text King ticks and if you go
away five I have king of two
that's nasty right
G3 with the very
last move right on time
so close to a draw right one tempo one
tempo my kingdom for tempo
and the I just heard from far that
engine says it's a Checkmate in 10 moves
I don't see checkmate
will you
um in the old days the romantic era
they prided themselves and they would
announce mate in eight wonderful Maiden
eight
but
if you fail to produce the mate Nate you
lost what yes so when you announced
Checkmate you had better be right
otherwise they're bringing you to the
shop you know
so Rook C1
it's funny so here but Bella can play
rookie to check King H1 and G3 right and
what I would still be trying to find
stalemate ideas but I still have that
pawn on A3 right not a chance for any
kind of stalemate no stalemates for you
yep
and um
we were afraid that we're going to get
five draws today but this lady said no
no no no no no no not so fast
uh what do we have on
the bouquet maybe now I'm seeing
Checkmate G3
so
okay three yeah okay so yeah and then
I'm seeing Checkmate as well
so if I can Rook here
okay you have to say it would be still
made if I didn't have the pawn right
but she's done it G3 and she's going for
that Queen ending right well here
am I also one Temple behind
very nice
maybe in this case a pew right yeah so
Checkmate intent
I bet you've already wouldn't uh say it
that way
okay no
yeah
so I think age to check and then King G4
King H3 is the fastest way but
what's the rush
let's torture it up on it what was that
sorry let me just Enviro is saying that
the quickest Checkmate was with H2 check
after kick G1
oh sorry okay you're H2 yes and then if
King H1 King G4 and King H3
ah and again what now the point of
having this Pawn is really prevalent
right yeah very because otherwise I
would have the stalemating
ideas yes right it would be a draw yeah
oops you can still move your palm she
can swipe it off the board yeah right
knock it off the board oops
foreign
yeah I think she'll play H2 now Gucci
too
King G1
because you don't want to play G2 and
allow King Gage too
which is probably also winning
you know I would just double check it to
be absolutely sure but I would be
attracted to this and this right you
know just to make sure that uh but
you're right H2 yeah King I was looking
at K2 if G2 was a mistake but I think it
might be because I can play Rook C3
check right
she played H2 so she's not giving any
chances
for white to survive exactly
and now it's Checkmate in five probably
King G4
which is Bella is very happy why it has
the pawn on A3 yes
so if constant on A3 is it actually
winning it has to be rated what is it
not there might be something to control
yeah I'll be a little bit um
worried about uh
but no I think you should I think King
E2
King F2 okay so is she going to play
Rook E2
and rookie one
let me update my board yeah we have King
F2 on the board and yes that's what she
said yeah that's what she's heading for
okay A5 rookie one and yes that's the
key promote to Queen first
ranking of two I think we're going to
see resignation and Shake very shortly
wow what a game what a game very this
whole tournament we've been seeing very
instructive end games
yes we had Bishop end game today Irina
crashing and signature Carson Mueller is
going to be very very happy for having
so many instructive games and there we
do have
uh a stoppage
and Bella won her game
and boy I yeah for for Bella this is a
huge huge relief but then the flip side
of that coin is in science and they go
uh oh you know like what's going what's
going on you know everything's gone
wrong I I was a pawn up I I thought I
was the one pressing and what a
turnaround chess can be very cruel truly
wow uh Almera jump in as oh first of all
let's just update our round oh no this
isn't round four tomorrow's pairing
these are tomorrow's parents
update for a moment but go ahead so we
have
right and Bella after today's win she's
playing the tournament leader Irina
Crush tomorrow nice uh pets will face
abdomalic and question you get another
tournament leader will play Anna zatoski
who also has been playing very well so
far it's got to be our Marquee matchup
when you look at just from the
perspective of who are our tournament
leaders and harika dronavali will play
gunai mamatada it's exactly and here are
the standings with all of the round all
the games completed from round three
and a half points out of three and Anna
satonsky saying how sweet it is I'll
take clear third if you don't mind very
nice and then with uh 50 we have four
players harika Nana Elizabeth and gunai
and unfortunately all the way to it's
ansaya who I didn't see this coming uh
three bosses in a row yeah I mean
somebody is going to lose but wow three
losses in a row that's tough
definitely
and I think we have Bella on the way
over for the interview yeah well we'll
hold the fort here for just a second
because I just wanted to go back because
you asked me a very pertinent question
here you said if the pawn on eight which
position of tripod is already on H2 when
the pawn is going to age two so uh let's
see here let's say here H2 right H1 H2
King H1 let's say White's Pawn is not on
E3 right so we're going to get rid of uh
the pawn
uh we're just going to make some rules
I don't know it comes back yes
so it's the same position with the a
pawn disappeared right but it's still
okay right it's still winning because of
Black's Kink placement but if King was
on G4 going the other way then I think
it's a draw ah yeah that was the that
was the king is already on E2 then it's
winning well it was actually kind of
funny because I think that was the the
simplest win was actually to bring the
king back right and if in this case the
a pawn isn't there then the the threat
of stalemate in check and that Rook did
you ever have that in one of your games
where you or your opponent had a mad
rook and you could give it away and make
us tell me yeah I've had it few times
but it was not like yesterday's game
between Anna and Bella right where he
was unexpected it was more like oh we
both saw it coming yeah yeah right
and with three rounds completed our
remaining schedule
right so we have total of nine rounds
and tomorrow players will be playing
round four and after round five they
will have one rest day and they'll come
back and finish with four rounds in a
row exactly split to the finish and also
at the end of course right at the end of
round nine if two or more players are
sharing first place they can be playoffs
on Tuesday
nice and uh the playoffs will not be
played on the same day as round nine
which I kind of like actually like just
because you know I type it first give me
a breather let me think about it
overnight let me prep for my opponent I
like that a lot of tournaments don't
have that uh luxury I have to say I
think for the players it feels a lot
better so but playoffs uh definite
possibility what do you think Almira
good chances we're gonna have a playoff
yes sir yeah I would say
well with the tie for first I don't know
I mean so in the in the previous
editions of the Cairns cup I mean I
remember Valentina had such a a big big
big dominating yeah a dominating
performance
um no I don't think we're gonna have a
playoff I think we will yeah and if
somebody's got to win
on this one nice and for us uh I was
just gonna say the game that Arena won
uh there was uh I don't know sometimes
you just kind of gifted everything's
going in your favor but this was a for
Nana that moved King D6 I mean that's
really regretting it we're gonna go to
Almera who's with guest
well uh congratulations you finally won
a game well I want to ask you about how
did you sleep this night or not after a
special after yesterday's game ah you
know when I played first time this case
cup uh I had a terrible insomnia so
that's why now I'm more prepared and I
have some pills for sleeping so I can
say that I slept well
so well uh for this was a very
interesting moment in your game I wanted
to ask you how did you feel about the
this position did you know that you were
not worse even though you were born down
uh yeah I know because
um as I remember there was a game like
uh this probably
topalo played I don't remember exactly
but I know that it's about equal so
that's why I decided to play this end
game so you were quite confident at that
stage yeah but after Rook D3 uh
I was not sure about taco no 23 but then
I liked these plans if I have C4 I had a
counter play I think
of course it was a very nice position
then I think that it was balanced and
here I have a question because we I know
that you're very tired and that it took
you uh
or your last forces to calculate here
and Rook seed yes that was did you
consider this move C3 yes at first I was
going to place a three but
btx3 B takes A3 and King did
no it will take say five yeah and there
was a very beautiful move here Knight C4
Rook A4 and here I don't know I don't
that was the move that was winning
actually yes
I did okay for no I missed a lot
it was not easy it's not obvious but you
played uh very well and I think that
this position is uh already lost uh yes
right but anyway I could win easily I
think I missed just
um
so and so
I was very tired yes I'm just of course
so well that was quite a long game we
will not keep you in the studio and I
hope to have you back
thank you very much
Bella or congratulations indeed very
very nice game and so important the end
several key moments E7 yes Knight takes
E7 C3 only move very precise she found
All the Right Moves very very very
deserving winner right NBA technique yes
exactly as once again we're just going
to take a quick Gander at our current
standings as we do have a tie for first
after three rounds of play lots of
Fighting Chess in this event so far
despite the fact we're not at 80 percent
today how disappointed how disappointing
but right we have two co-leaders Carson
you can crush with two and a half out of
three and another task in clear third
with two points absolutely very nice and
I'm Gonna Leave it to you Almira for
final thoughts as we wrap up the third
round of the Karen's cup wow it was
another exciting round although too many
draws to my face
do not reflect the the what happened on
the board yeah it was
well a lot of struggle and well John
Sayer castled long right it says a lot
about how strong the tournament is so at
this moment I think she really needs to
change something in her routine I don't
know maybe cut her hair
there's something really dramatic
and uh well I will be really very
curious to see uh well how it will go
tomorrow absolutely well I just wanted
to say yeah it's another great day uh
calling all the action with you Nasi and
with you Amira I still want to settle a
name for our chess engine uh at the end
of the tournament well no I really
needed there earlier so when I refer to
Yoda we know where we're going on this
one but it's been a lot of fun for us we
hope you enjoyed it thank you for
sharing your day with us tell all your
friends where you're hanging out be sure
to sh to join our social media subscribe
and join us again tomorrow same time
good night everyone
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited